ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
IS NOW CALLED TO ORDER OF OUR
HEARING TODAY WILL BE FOCUSED
ON CONTRACTING ADMIT STE THIS
EMERGENCY I'M THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR JOINING US- BEFORE WE GET
STARTED ON. SUBJECT TO HAND.
LET ME TOUCH ON SOME LOGISTICS
AND FIFTY ITEMS FOR EVERYONE
HE'S HERE IN THE CHAMBER WITH
US AND ALSO I LISTENING AT HOME
SO DUE TO THE CURRENT STATE
HOME ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN HERE AND
CHANGE AND THREW OUT CAPITAL
BILL. ONLY ABLE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY AND AS WE GET. AT THE END
OF OUR HEARING WILL BE OPENING
THIS UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND
REVIEW DETAILS AT THAT POINT.
WE CAN PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON. IN THE SPACE WE CAN A
COP OUR MEMBERS A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA. SO WE MAINTAIN SIX
FEET OF SPACING THERE ARE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO.
HEARING I WENT TO I THINK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR FORBEARANCE
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT THESE
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE.
THE PEOPLE AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ENSURING THAT
WE ARE BEING SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE AND PRACTICING
DISTANCING. AT THIS. IS AS WE
NOW AN UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN TRULY
EXTRAORDINARY STEPS TO COMBAT
OF IT NINETEEN THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP WE TOGETHER ARE
MEETING THIS CRISIS FLATTENING
THE CURVE BUILDING SURGE
CAPACITY ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND ENSURE
THAT WE ARE IN A POSITION TO DO
AND SAFELY AND RESPONSIBLY.
PAST TENSE REALLY HERCULEAN
EFFORT HAS BEEN UNDER BUILD
SURGE ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM THIS HAS
INCLUDED THE PROCUREMENT OF
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF UNITS
OF PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. UNFORTUNATELY IN THE
MIX. THIS HORRIFIC CRISIS THERE
ARE THOSE WHO HAVE SEEN AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EXPLOITATION
AND IN THE GLOBAL RASH FOUR PP
EXPLOITATION HAS BEEN SADLY
DRIVE. FROM ABUSE HAS BEEN
RAMPANT. IN RECENT WEEKS THE
STATE HAS HEARD INTO CONTRACTS
OF MORE THAN ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS PER PP. AND WE
HAVE SEEN SOME NINE FIGURE
CONTRACTS THAT HAVE FALLEN
THROUGH OR BEEN CANCELED AND
INCIDENTS HAVE RICK QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE NEXT. HOUR BUT- EIGHT
TWO I REALLY UNDERSTAND FOR
THINGS NUMBER ONE THE LESSONS
THAT HAVE BEEN LEARNED AS WE
HAVE NAVIGATED THIS GLOBAL RACE
FOR SOME PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
NUMBER TWO THE PROTOCOLS AND A
CONTRACT THAT HAVE BEEN
STRENGTHENED AND ADOPTED IT AS
A RESULT OF THESE WEAPONS.
NUMBER THREE EIGHT WHAT IS AND
GAPS STOVER WHAT ARE WE DOING
TO CLOSE THOSE NUMBER FOUR WHAT
IS A STRAP AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT MISSION
CRITICAL. PEACE IS. PLACE FOR
TO RISK THE NINETEENTH AND TO
MOVE IN RECOVERY SO WHEN I
THANK OUR PANELISTS FOR JOINING
US TODAY- AND ALSO. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIRELESS WORK AND FOR
LEADERSHIP AS WE HAVE FRONTED
THIS CRISIS. AS WE HELP BRING
IN NOT A- REALLY AND CHAU
WATERS. THE FOUR WE ARE HERE
FROM OUR PANELISTS I WENT TO
OPEN IT UP FOR OUR MEMBERS
HERE. TO MAKE THEIR OPENING
REMARKS I JUST WANNA REMIND
EVERYONE PLEASE WE CAN KEEP OUR
REMARKS TO. UNDER THREE MINUTES
AND PLEDGE EYES IF I IF I YOUNG
FOR MY SURE THAT WE'VE GOT
PLENTY OF TIME TO FOCUS ON THE
TOP RIGHT HAND. I THINK YOU
CHAIR YES. AS FOR THE HEARING
THANK ALSO TO CHAIR. A TO
INVITE YOU TO MAKE YOUR OPENING
REMARKS FIRST AND THEN IN MY
VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING. MY
PARTICIPATION ON BEHALF OF THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE- AS RELATES TODAY'S
AGENDA AND STATE CONTRACTING
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT THEY'RE
ALWAYS BE CRITICS. WHO CAN IN
THE STATE FOR ACTION KLAY. OR
NOT QUICKLY ENOUGH WITHOUT PP
AND OTHER SUPPLIES PEOPLE DIE.
AND SO SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I
LAND FIRMLY ON THE SIDE OF
ACTING QUICKLY DURING A CRISIS
AND ACCEPTING A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF RISK AS A RESULT. I DON'T
BELIEVE OURROLE A IS TO
CHASTISE. BUT RATHER. WE'RE
HERE TODAY TO STERILIZE. OUR
MISTAKES WAS SUNSHINE IN PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY I LOOK FORWARD TO-
LISTENING TO THE PANELS AND-
ENGAGING IN A DIALOGUE WITH
EXECUTIVE IN OTHERS- ON STEPS
WE CAN TAKE GOING FORWARD TO DO
BETTER AND ALSO TO CELEBRATE
THE SUCCESS. THAT HAVE THAT WE
SELL THANK YOU GET THE CHAIRMAN
OF MEMBERS AND A LOOK FORWARD-
TO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING IN THIS
OVERSIGHT OF THE GETS A VITALLY
IMPORTANT. APPRECIATE YOUR
INVITING ME AS CHAIR OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY. HE ARE
FULL AND MEDIA OF GENERATOR A
LOT OF INTEREST FROM A LOT OF
MEMBERS- FROM BOTH HOUSES ON
THIS TOPIC THAT WE WILL EXPLORE
LATER TODAY. AND IT'S A- UPON
US AS LEGISLATORS PROVIDE. THE
ACCOUNT. AT A TIME LIKE THIS.
AND ASK VITAL QUESTIONS OF HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
STILL ENSURING ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY EVEN AN
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS LIKE THIS
WHAT HAVE WE DONE AND- US
PRICES. YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAVE.
OR NAY. URGENCY WE'VE HAD IN
THE STATE OF WE PRO. GUIDELINES
DO WE STILL FOLLOW HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC DOLLAR
WAS STILL BEING WELL SPENT AND
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
TODAY'S HEARING SHE THE
OPPORTUNITY- TO BE A PART OF
THIS HEARING ON OR TO. TO THE-
AN UNPRECEDENTED TYPE I DO WANT
TO SAY THAT I BELIEVE THE
GOVERNOR'S ON THE LAND. AT THIS
MOMENT HE'S MET THE MOMENT LIKE
HE LIKES TO SAY. AND SO- I LOOK
FORWARD TO BRING SUNSHINE TO
THIS AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. BE A PART OF
THIS AND ALSO TO- HAVE A COUPLE
OF OPENING REMARKS. THE FIRST
THING I WANT TO DO IS TO. I
THINK SEND OUT KUDOS WERE KUDOS
OR DO PARTICULARLY. TO THE
ESTATE TREASURE FEEL TOMORROW I
THINK SHE HAS DONE A REMARKABLE
JOB PARTICULARLY IN ONE OF THE
MORE DIFFICULT THAN WHAT SOME
HAVE TERM SORT OF A FISHY- THE
CONTRACT. OF AND AS A RESULT
THIS BLUE FLAME DEAL PROBABLY
HEAR MORE ABOUT IT. A HUNDRED
MILLION AND NINETY FIVE MASKS
THEY WERE BANKERS INVOLVED
THAT'S AWESOME REAL FISHY.
THINGS GOING ON. THE CALIFORNIA
NOW TREASURER. DID SOME REALLY
GOOD WORK A LOOK INTO THIS AS
WELL. AND REALLY DID HER JOB
WELL- AND THEN SHE CALLED THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND SAID
THERE IS SOMETHING FIFTY. GOING
ON HERE SO I WANT TO COMMEND
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TAKEN ON
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF BEING A
WATCHDOG IN AND TAKING ON
RESPONSIBILITY OF DOING THEIR-
THEIR DUE DILIGENCE- THIS IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE. BUT WE DO HAVE A
COLLECTION. OF CONTRACTS THAT
ARE EITHER HAVE BORDERLINE
FAILED OR OR HAVE FAILED.
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
WITH BLUE FLAME A BILLION WITH
B. Y. DE. EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
WITH- BEAR MOUNTAIN THAT'S
NEARLY THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
CONTRACTS WITH SERIOUS
DIFFICULTIES. AND SO I HAVE A
TWO OR THREE QUESTIONS I'D LIKE
TO ASK LATER ON THE FLESH OUT
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT SOME
OF US HAVE ABOUT THIS. INCREASE
APR UNITY OF BEING A PART OF
THIS AS- MY FRIEND I'M A
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. POINTED OUT
THE THIS DIFFICULT DUTY. AT A
TIME WHEN WE NEED TO HAVE.
CLARITY BUT WE NEED
ACCOUNTABILITY- AND SO WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY THANKFULLY TO
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE DONE.
OBVIOUSLY LOOK AT IT AND SAY
WELL THAT WAS A KIND OF A GOOF.
BUT ALSO FIGURE OUT WAYS THAT
WE DON'T MAKE THOSE GROUPS
AGAIN GOING FORWARD. AND THE
FUNDAMENTAL THING I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE OUT OF ALL OF
THIS. IS TO GET THE REAP VERSUS
THE QUALITY COMPANIES THAT KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING THAT CAN
PERFORM THEIR CONTRACTS. YEAH
PP EASE INTO THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT NEED THEM THE MOST
WELL WE CAN'T HAVE IS ANOTHER.
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OF IF THE
CONTRACT. AND I THINK THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO. DO
SOME OF THE DUE DILIGENCE AND
SOME OF THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
SOME QUESTIONS THAT WE WILL DO.
Q. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ANY REMARKS. REX SCENE
NINE- WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST PANEL I DIRECTOR
KILLER DG THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BEING HERE. HI WELL THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. ABOUT THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
GLOBAL PANDEMIC. PARTICULARLY
THE STATE'S FIRST EMERGENCY
PROCUREMENT AND DISTRIBUTION OF
LIFESAVING PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT ARE AS WE HAVE COME
TO KNOW IT PP. THIS IS REALLY
BEEN THE LARGEST DISASTER
LOGISTICS AND COMMODITY
DISTRIBUTION OPERATION IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR STATE. TO
WORKING ALL PREVIOUS DISASTER
OPERATIONS AS YOUR WHERE ARE
AND AS HAS BEEN REPORTED ALMOST
NONSTOP BY THE MEDIA THE WORLD
MEDIA THIS PANDEMIC ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY CAUSED AND
CONTINUES TO CALL US A WITH
WIDE SHORTAGE OF PP. WITH
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS
HERMANCE AND PRIVATE SECTOR
BUSINESSES SIMULTANEOUSLY
COMPETING FOR SCARCE RESOURCES
PARTICULARLY AND NINETY FIVE
MASKS. GOVERNMENT INCLUDING OUR
OWN FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
SPARED FROM THIS. IN THE EARLY
DAYS OF THE PANDEMIC WE WERE
CONFRONTED WITH MALL THIS AND
PROJECTIONS THAT INDICATED OUR
MEDICAL INFRASTRUCTURE WAS A
GREAT RISK OF BEING OVER ON. B.
E. WAS IN SHORT SUPPLY AND
MEDICAL PROVIDERS ARE RAISING.
OF THE ALARM THAT THEY HAD
INSUFFICIENT STOCKPILES.
WITHOUT A P. B. MEDICAL
PROVIDERS WOULD LIKELY BECOME
INFECTED THEMSELVES REDUCING
THE CAPACITY OF. THE SYSTEM
WHEN WE NEEDED IT MOST. STATE
YOUR PLACE IN THE POSITION OF
COMPETING AGAINST EACH OTHER
AGAINST OUR OWN FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WITH GOVERNMENTS
AROUND THE WORLD. WITH THE SAME
PRECIOUS RESOURCE. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PRODUCTION OF PP
OCCURS IN CHINA. WITH SOME
SPECIFIC ITEMS ITALY. BOTH
EPICENTERS OF MAJOR VIRUS
OUTBREAKS AND IMPACTS. IN FACT
IN CHINA THE SCALE AND SPREAD
OF THE VIRUS RESULTED IN EITHER
THE SHUT DOWN OF THE MAJORITY
OF PP MANUFACTURING. DIRECTLY
THIS INCLUDED COMPANIES MF THAT
MANUFACTURED THE AND NINETY
FIVE MASKS SURGICAL MASKS
GOGGLES GALLONS FACE SHIELDS
AND GLOVES. IN IN THE PROVINCE
WHERE THE OUTBREAK WAS MOST
SEVERE WAS WHERE THE WORLD'S
PRODUCTION OF CRITICALLY
NECESSARY SWABS FOR TESTING
WERE MANIFEST. AND WHILE WE
WERE IN CLOSE CONTACT WITH THE
MYSTIC SUPPLIERS. THEM THE
MAJORITY DEPENDED ON THOSE
FOREIGN SOURCES OF
MANUFACTURING THAT I JUST
MENTIONED AND MATERIALS. AND
THEY WERE EITHER UNABLE TO FILL
ORDERS WERE NOT ABLE TO START
SUPPLYING THE QUANTITY NEEDED
UNTIL FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY. AS
WITH ALL OUR NORMAL STATE
SUPPLIERS OF PP THAT WE HAVE ON
CONTRACT HAD NO ACCESS TO AND
NINETY FIVE OR MOST OF THE
OTHER COMMODITIES. BY MARCH.
MOVING REVIEW AND ASSESSMENT OF
WORST CASE SCENARIO MODELING
AND ASSOCIATE ASSISTING THE PP
NEED. WE WERE ABLE TO SET A
TARGET GOAL OF PURCHASING FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION AND NINETY FIVE
MASKS. FOUR HUNDRED BILLION
SURGICAL MASKS TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FACE SHE BILLS ONE
BILLION NITRILE GLOVES SETS.
AND ONE HUNDRED MILLION GAPS.
THIS WOULD BE THE SUPPLY OUR
HOSPITAL CARE SYSTEMS ARE
RESPOND EARNERS ARE- SENIOR
CARE FACILITIES ETCETERA. AT
THE SAME TIME THE NUMBER OF AND
NINETY FIVE MASS. WE HAD BEEN
ABLE TO SOURCE WAS LESS THAN
ONE MILLION. WE WERE ALREADY
SEEN AT THAT TIME PRICES ON
AVERAGE OF SIX TO SEVEN DOLLARS
PER MASK. WITH THIS HIGHEST
TWELVE DOLLARS PER MASK. I WANT
TO REPEAT THAT SIX TO SEVEN
DOLLARS PER MASK AS HIGH AS
TWELVE DOLLARS BASS. THIS WAS
NOT UNIQUE THE CALIFORNIA THIS
WAS ALL THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES. HUNDREDS OF VENDORS
WE'RE CALLING WHOMEVER THEY
COULD IN THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER AS WELL AS MANY OF OUR
ELECTED LEADERS INCLUDING
BABIES MY VIEW AT THE LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS ALL
SAY THEY HAD A LINE ON SLICE.
AND COULD DELIVER IMMEDIATELY.
IT HAS BEEN SAID THAT THIS WAS
THE WILD WILD WEST. IT WAS
ACTUALLY THE WILD WILD WORLD.
THE MARKET IS BEYOND VOLATILE.
THE STATE HAD VERY LITTLE
LEVERAGE TO BARGAIN WITH JUST
AS WE WERE NOTIFIED OF A
POTENTIAL SOURCE AND THE SOURCE
APPEAR LEGITIMATE IT WAS LOST
TO ANOTHER BUYER. GIVEN THE
OVERWHELMING GLOBAL NEED IT WAS
A SELLER'S MARKET AND THE
SELLERS RIDDICK TV NEGOTIABLE
TERMS. INCLUDING ADVANCE
PAYMENT OTHER TERMS TO WHICH
THE STATE WOULD NOT NORMALLY
AGREE. I THINK IT WOULD HELP TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT AS WE GOT
UP TO THIS POINT. SO THAT YOU
CAN UNDERSTOOD NORMALLY OF THE
SITUATION. IN JANUARY AS COVERT
NINETEEN BECAUSE THE ENTIRE
CITY OF WUHAN IN THE WHO BY
PROVINCE OF CHINA TO QUARANTINE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CREATION PLAN CALIFORNIA ROSE
TO MEET THE NEED WHEN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT BEGAN REPATRIATION
FLIGHTS TO BRING AMERICAN
CITIZENS HOME. CALLAWAY YES AT
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER AND
WORK WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
AGENCY AND OTHER FEDERAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND STATE IS TO
ASSIST AND COORDINATE THE
REPATRIATION OF THE U. S.
CITIZENS BACK IN THE CALIFORNIA.
FOR LANDED MARCH YOUR BASS TRAP
FOR SPACE MARIE CORPS STATION
MIRAMAR IN LATE JANUARY AND
EARLY FEBRUARY. CALIFORNIA'S
SERVED AS THE FOR THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS TO RETURN HOME SAFELY
THIS REQUIRE CLOSE COORDINATION
ON THE STATE'S PART. WITH NOT
ONLY MULTIPLE FEDERAL AND STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS BUT
ALSO LOCAL FIRE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT COMMUNITY
TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
LOGISTIC NEEDS IS APPROPRIATE
SHOULD BRING MATHIS OF FOR THE
RE CREATED CITIZENS. WHO WERE
THE FOURTEEN A POTTERY. THE US
TO TRIPLE. TRY WHICH WE COULD
INTENSIFY OF IMMEDIATELY
RETURNING TO THE U. S. WITH
ALMOST ALL PASSING THROUGH OR
ENDING UP IN CALIFORNIA. ON
FEBRUARY FIRST WERE SIX
CONFIRMED. COVERT NINETEEN CASE
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE MONTH
OF FEBRUARY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. YOU TO MY IS AND LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS ON CONTACT BEING.
STATE IN LATE FEBRUARY THE
STATE ENHANCES CAPABILITIES
DEDICATED TO COVERT NINETEEN
RESPONSE AFTER THE FIRST CASE A
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION. IN THE
STATE OF KURT. AND I DO HAVE AN
FROM TIMELINE TO GIVE YOU SOME
KIND OF THAT AS WELL AS A- I'M
MORE FOR THE GOVERNOR THE
DECLARED A STATE EMERGENCY
STATEWIDE TO BUILD ON THE WORK
ALREADY UNDER WAY BY THIS. AND
ENGAGE LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT. IN
A- OF A HIGHER OPEN NINETEEN
INFECTION THAT WE EXPECTED. AT
THE SAME TIME SOURCE REQUEST
FOR PP ALREADY ACCELERATING
PROMPTING THE STATE OPERATION
CENTERS CENTER TO BEGIN
DISTRIBUTING THE TWENTY ONE
MILLION. FIVE MATH WE HAD IN
OUR RESERVE. THEN ON MARCH SIX
CALLOW YES RECEIVED
NOTIFICATION FROM THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY THAT
THE GRAND PRINCESS CRUISE SHIP
WAS HEADED BACK. TO THE STATE
OF. WHAT THIS NORMALLY PORTED
IN SANFORD IN IT WE WENT TO
BEFORE COMING BACK TO
CALIFORNIA TO OFF LOAD IN PICK
UP PASS. OR AGAIN SETTING SAIL
AWAY. THEN WHY IS THAT THERE AN
UNKNOWN NUMBER OF SICK PEOPLE
ON THE SHIP. CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTED THE CDC AND THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WITH SEVERAL HIGH
PROFILE SORTIES TRANSPORTING
MEDICAL STAFF AND NECESSARY PP
OUT AND PRINCESS WHILE STILL
IT'S- THIS INCLUDED TESTING
STAFF AND PASSENGERS ON BOARD
AND SO EVACUATIONS. OF SICK IT.
BRING IN EX INVOLVING MULTIPLE
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT WE WERE
ABLE TO SECURE A PLAN FOR THE
SHIP TO BIRTH AT A SEAT
LOCATION AT THE PORT. SURE THE
PASSENGERS TWENTY ONE OF THAT.
SEVEN TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVERT EIGHTEEN COULD DISEMBARK
SAFELY AND RECEIVE MEDICAL
TREATMENT. THE FIRST PASSENGERS
DISEMBARKED ON MARCH NINTH AND
THE LAST PASSAGE OF THE SUPPORT
ON MARCH SIXTEENTH. ALL
PASSENGERS INCLUDING ALL OTHER
U. S. IT IS AND FOREIGN
NATIONALS QUARANTINE TRAVIS FOR
SPACE MORE AIR STATION AND
OTHER IF. ESTABLISHED BY THE
STATE. THERE WAS NO CALL NINE
SPREAD INTO THE COMMUTER.
BEFORE RETURNING HOME. THIS WAS
A MAJOR OPERATION IN THE RIGHT.
ANY DEMANDED AN EXTENSIVE
REQUIREMENT UP FOR CALIFORNIA
TO PROVIDE LARGE QUANTITIES OF
THE EMBEDDED PERSONNEL AND THE
JUST FOR THE US HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES YOU SEE. THIS
CALL NINETEEN CONTINUE
ANNOUNCED THAT OTHER MEANS OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY OR MORE
SHOULD BE RESCHEDULED TO CANCEL
AND GATHERINGS OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE AT HIGHER RISK FOR
SEVERE ILLNESS FROM CARPET
NINETEEN. TO NUMBER. FOR ALL
FOLLOWING SOCIAL DISTANCING
GUIDELINE. OUR MARCH SIXTEENTH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE GUIDANCE
RECOMMENDED THAT ADULTS OVER
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND THOSE
WHO COMPROMISED INSIST OR
SERIOUS CHRONIC MEDICAL
CONDITIONS SUCH QUARANTINE AT
HOME. I'M NOT. THE GOVERNOR OF
THE STATE BORDER URGING ALL
CALIFORNIA A CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
IS TO REMAIN A NONESSENTIAL
CALIFORNIA TO REMAIN HOME A
FIRST. STATE IN THE COUNTRY TO.
TWENTY THE GUY THE REQUESTED
AND THE PRESIDENT APPROVED A
MAJOR DISASTER DECLARATION FOR
CAL YEAH FOR DIRECT BUT WAS.
EMERGENCY PROTECT. AT THIS
AGAIN CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST
STATE TO REQUEST AND RECEIVE A
MAJOR PRESIDENTIAL DISASTER
DECLARATION. THE SAME WEEK
FOLLOW REQUEST BY THE STATE U.
S. HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY CALIFORNIA'S RECEIVED.
ITS INITIAL ALLOTMENT OF PP
FROM THE STREET THE NATIONAL
STOCKPILE. THIS A LOT MEANT.
HOWEVER WAS 25% OF WHAT WAS
EXPECTED AND OF THAT BATTLE
ALLOTMENT WAS SHORT IN QUANTITY.
THIS A LOT MAY CONSIST OF ONLY
THREE HUNDRED AND 580-003-0080
ONE AND NINETY FIVE MASKED
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND SEVEN EARNED THIRTY
SURGICAL MESH. WHAT HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTY
FIVE SHE 1-003-000-0540 FOUR
SURGICAL GOWNS SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT FOR ALL. SEVEN
HUNDRED AT THE ONE THOUSAND AND
FORTY ONE GLOVE SETS.
THROUGHOUT THE ENSUING. THE
STATE CONTINUE TO REQUEST
REQUEST FOR OUR FULL ALLOTMENT
OF THE NATIONAL STOCKPILE. AND
IN A MORE TO FASHION THAN WHAT
THE FIRST ALLOTMENT AND THAT.
AS WE WERE ALREADY FALLING
BEHIND ON AVAILABILITY OF PP.
IN ALL THE STATE ONLY RISK. ALL
TIME ONLY 75% OF OUR TOTAL
ALLOTMENT. AS REFERENCE THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF S. AND S.
SHOULD INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING
TWENTY FIVE MILLION AND NINETY
FIVE TEN MILLION SURGICAL MASS
SIX THOUSAND GALLONS THREE
THOUSAND FEET SHE'LL SIX AND
GLOCK THOUSAND GOGGLES. ONE
HUNDRED COVER IN AND WE ONLY
RECEIVED 25% ALSO ON TOP OF
THAT THE ESSENCE ALSO BEING
SHORT ON EXPECT THE PPV
QUANTITIES SPOKE TO THE PP
SHORTAGE CHALLENGE THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ITSELF WAS
ALSO FACING AND THEIR KNOWLEDGE
OF SOURCES. COMMODITY THE TIME
HE FOUND. WELL HELLO WAS
WORKING TO SECURE PP OUR OWN
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UNBEKNOWNST
TO US. AT EMBARK ON THEIR A
STRATEGIC APPROACH. THEY
ENTERED INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH
WITH SEVERAL OF THE NATION'S
LARGEST MEDICAL SUPPLY
COMPANIES. THE LAUNCH IT IS
BEING COME TO WHAT IS COME TO
BE KNOWN AS OPERATION YOUR
BRIDGE. THE OPERATION WHICH IS
ON GOING TODAY CONSISTED OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UTILIZING
DOD CONTRACT AIRCRAFT AND
BUYERS. SCOUR PP MANUFACTURERS
IN CHINA TO OBTAIN AS MUCH PP
AS POSSIBLE. THE US GOVERNMENT
WOULD THEN BRING THE
COMMODITIES BACK TO THE U. S.
TO DISTRIBUTED IN THE FOLLOWING
MANNER 50% ACOSTA TWENTY TO
SELL TO THEIR CUSTOMERS
NORMALLY HOSPITALS 20% TO THE
MEDICAL SUPPLY COMPANY TO SELL
TO OTHERS. INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE LOOKING
FOR PP WITH PRIORITY TO HOT
SPOT PORTIONS IN THE COUNTRY
WHICH AT THE TIME WAS NEW YORK
NEW JERSEY MICHIGAN AREA. AND
THIRTY TO FIFTY MA FOR PATIENTS
THE STRATEGIC NOW UPON THIS
PROGRAM WALL JUST NOW STARTING
TO EASE SOME OF THE BACKLOG OF
PP REQUIRED. IN HOSPITAL CPAS
PLEA. LITTLE COMPOUND THE FALSE
STAGE WERE FOR ENOUGH PP
THROUGH SOURCING. WHAT WAS LEFT
COULD ONLY BE OBTAINED- IN THE
ASIAN MARKET WHAT WAS
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WAS LEFT COULD
ONLY BE OBTAINED IN THE ASIAN
MARKET WAS ALMOST 1% IN
ADDITION TO THE CHALLENGES WE
FACED WITH ONGOING LIMITED
COMMODITIES THAT REQUIRED
EXTENSIVE NAVIGATION. ARMONK
VENDORS FRAUD. PROMISES NOT
CAPPED OVERSTATED CAPABILITIES
AND AN OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS AND COMPANIES
WORKING HARD TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE SITUATION. FURTHER WE
WERE ALSO SEEN CASES WHERE
STATE'S WORST WERE SUCCESSFULLY
GETTING PP FORCE FIELD ONLY TO
HAVE THOSE SHIPMENTS DIVERTED
ORDER SUPERSEDED THE US
GOVERNMENT. WE IN FACT IN
CALIFORNIA LAW SHIPMENTS OF
SWAMPS AND SHIELDS TO THIS
SITUATION AND WE HAVE SEEN THE
VERSIONS OF THREE M. AND NINETY
FIVE MASS BORDER. TO THE U. S.
GOVERNMENT. LASTLY GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF VOLATILITY IN THE PP
MARKET AND THE AMOUNT OF
CRITICISM THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT WAS GETTING. THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT STARTED TO
SHUT DOWN PP MANTA ACTORS AND
STOP SHIP AND COME UP HE'S OUT
OF CHINA. AGAIN THIS SIR YES WE
LOST SEVERAL CRITICAL AND
NINETY FIVE ORDERS. AS A RESULT
OF THIS. EVEN WITH THE
TREMENDOUS PRESSURE OF ALL THIS
GOING ON. WITH THE NEED TO
RAPIDLY MOVE TO GET PP FOR
LIFESAVING OPERATIONS. IN REAL
TIME IN CONTRAST TO WHAT HAS
BEEN REPORTED. IN THE MEDIA THE
PROCUREMENT TEAM I USE THE
EXPERIENCE THEY HAVE- IT IS
INSURED BY NO MONEY HAS LOST
AND WE ONLY PAY FOR WHAT OF.
SEE COMPARE TO OTHER STATE THAT
FORTY FIVE AND A POTENTIALLY
LOS THEM. LET ME BE CLEAR. AS
THE PRESSURE TO PROCURE
LIFESAVING EQUIPMENT THE
THOUSANDS OF OFFERS COMING IN
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THE PROMISES
OF DELIVERIES NOT MAD. WITH OUR
EXTENSIVE READY THAT WAS IN
PLACE AT THE TIME- OUR SAFETY
NET THAT WE USE THROUGH NORMAL
DISASTER OPERATIONS AND
PROCUREMENT. BUT THEN NOW
HAVING TO DO IT IS LITERALLY ON
STEROIDS I GUESS YOU COULD SAY
WITH THE AMOUNT OF TIME FRAMES
AND RECALL AS WE HAD- IT WAS.
I'M REALLY AMERICA ALL IN MANY
WAYS THAT THERE WASN'T MORE-
CHALLENGES THAT WE- WE HAD.
SOME WATER- MY BACK MY MASS.
OVER THE DUE TO MANY OF THESE
HEARINGS WITH A MASK ON SO. NOW
WE KNOW HOW DOCTORS AND NURSES
MUST FEEL BEING IN THESE MASS
ALL THEIR- UP. I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES. WE WERE CONFRONTED
WITH THAT RESULTED IN AS
ENHANCING OUR VETTING ENHANCING
OUR EXISTING VETTING PROCESS.
IN REAL TIME GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. OF THE NEW NORM-
THAT WE WERE FACING WITH
REGARDS TO- IN THAT WITH
REQUIREMENTS AT HAND. THIS IS
ONE THAT. WAS REFERENCED
EARLIER IN THE OPENING COMMENTS
BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MARCH
TWENTY THIRD ONE OF THE
HUNDREDS OF LEADS COMING IN
THAT DAY. OUR HELLO YES WE
RECEIVED A REFERRED A REFERRAL
ABOUT A COMPANY CALLED BLUE
FLAME. AND FOR THE COMPANY TO
GIGI YES SERVING IN ITS ROLE AS
OUR JUDICATA- WE CALL EMERGENCY
SUPPORT FUNCTION SEVEN- TO DO
THAT AS IT IS DONE COUNTLESS
TIMES. THE VENDOR INDICATE
VENDOR INDICATED THAT. THEY HAD
ONE HUNDRED MILLION AND NINETY
FIVE MASKS IN THE PORT OF LOS
LONG BEACH. THE DDS TEAM ASK
THE CALIFORNIA BASED OWNER
QUESTIONS. TO ASSESS WHETHER
THE COMPANY ACTUALLY HAVE THE
PRODUCT AND COULD DELIVER IT.
THE CALLER CONFIRMED THAT HE
HAD MASS AND OFFERED AGAIN THE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION AND NINETY
FIVE MASS. THE CALLER PROVIDED
A QUOTE AT FOUR DOLLARS AND
SEVENTY SIX CENTS PER MASK
WHICH AT THE TIME WAS ONE OF
THE LOWEST WE HAD SEEN. OUR TO
DATE COMPARED TO PURCHASES THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE AT EIGHT FIFTY
AND FIVE FIFTY AND FIVE DOLLARS.
THE CALLER PROVIDED PRODUCT
SPECIFICATIONS THAT MET STATE
pPROVIDED A SHIPPING SCHEDULE
CALL PROVIDE INFORMATION ON THE
MANUFACTURER. THE INDIVIDUAL
REPRESENTED HIMSELF AS A
COMPANY OWNER. WHO INDICATED
THAT HE WAS A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT WHO HAD A BUSINESS IN
GOOD STANDING REGISTER WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. THE COMPANY
WAS A US COMPANY USING AN
AMERICAN BANK. THE CALL ALSO
INDICATED THAT THEY BE THAT
THEY WOULD REQUIRE ADVANCE
PAYMENT WHICH WAS THE STANDARD
AT THE TIME THERE WAS BE
REQUIRED ON ANYONE SUPPLYING
DIRECT. SUPPLIES FROM CHINA
GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT I'VE
MENTIONED BEFORE. AGAIN IN THE
CONTEXT OF ALL THAT WAS GOING
ON AND THE NEED TO MOVE SWIFTLY
AS WELL AS THE CONCERN TO
OBTAIN THE NECESSARY PP THAT
THE VENDOR APPEAR TO HAVE THE
SUPPLY AT A GOOD PRICE AND
GIVEN THE INFORMATION OBTAINED
REAR YOU'D THAT DID NOT DEPICT.
ANY DEROGATORY INFORMATION OF
ME THE TEAM MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE ORDER. OF THE AS WELL THE
TEAM AT THE SAME TIME HOWEVER
WAS BALANCING THAT ORDER WITH
AN ORDER WITH DOMESTIC THREE AM
CORPORATION AT THE SAME TIME-
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THEY
SOURCE A SIMILAR A NUMBER OF
MASKS. INCLINATION OF THE TEAM.
PASS THROUGH THREE AM. HOWEVER
THREE M. CAME BACK AND
INDICATED THAT THE TIME THEY
COULD NOT DELIVER THE PRODUCT
AND TO DAY THEY'RE STILL HAVING
TROUBLE DELIVERING PRODUCTS. OF
THE MULTIPLE CHECKS AND BALANCE
THIS WAS ONE THAT WAS
IDENTIFIED. ULTIMATELY UP BY
THE BANK- AS WE MOVE WE DID
WIRE MONEY ON THIS ONE APPEARED
TO BE LEGITIMATE UP. AND THE-
THANKS NORM. WATER ORDER TO THE
STATE AND REPORTED TO THE STATE
TO THE TREASURER AND TO
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES-
LITERALLY SIMULTANEOUSLY. TO
DATE. WE HAVE NOT ACTUALLY
CANCEL THIS ORDER AS A REMAINS
OPEN PENDING AN INVESTIGATION.
THIS ONE IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
COUNTLESS NUMBER OF ACTIVITIES
THAT WERE GOING ON THAT
REPRESENTED SOME FORM OF- MISS
REPRESENTATION- OR POSSIBLY
FRAUD IN A TIME. WHEN THE BILL
THE OUR PUBLIC SAFETY ALL OF US
WERE RESPONDING TO BE ABLE TO
SOURCE MATERIAL IN PEOPLE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IT. IN ALL
GIVEN THE THOUSANDS OF
COMMODITIES VETTED THE
TREMENDOUS PRESSURE TO SOURCE
AND THE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
AND THAT WE WERE DEALING WITH.
THERE WERE EMILY THE FEW THAT
REQUIRED US TO EITHER CANCEL
THE CONTRACT OR SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT. HE ROBIN ENTIRE
ENDEAVOR AND WE'RE TALKING%
ABOUT TEN THOUSANDS OF ORDERS.
TO DATE NOT ONE DIME. NOT ONE
DIME OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS HAS
BEEN LOST. IT IS BECOME VERY
CLEAR TO US THAT GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THE VOLATILE
COMPETITIVE MARKET FUEL BY
SCARCE RESOURCES. THE LIMITED
AVAILABILITY OF D. B. M. THE
UNPREDICTABLE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT ALONG WITH. ALL OF
THIS ACTIVITY THAT WAS GOING
ON- BY PEOPLE WHO WERE JUST
NEFARIOUS- THAT WE NEEDED TO-
YOU KNOW. CONTINUE DOWN A PATH
BACK YES ULTIMATELY. OUR
ULTIMATE OBJECTIVE WAS GET. AND
I'LL CONTINUE DOWN THE PATH
WHERE WE WERE GOING ONE OFFS
AND BEING ABLE TO PULL FROM ONE
VENDOR ANOTHER WAS ON SYSTEM
WILL. WE NEEDED A MORE JIJIGA
PRO WHICH- WE LEVERAGE THE
SYSTEMS IN CONCEPTS WE HAVE
UTILIZED IN MANY PREVIOUS
DISASTERS TO DEVELOP A MULTI
PRONGED STRATEGY. TO BUILD A
MORE LEVEL I AM ALL IT'S A
STATE OF A PIPELINE. TO MEET
THE NEEDS NOW. AND FOR THE
DURATION OF THE EVENT. AS WELL
UP HERE FOR THE NEEDS NECESSARY
TO RE OPEN THE ECONOMY. AS IN
FEES WILL NEED TO UTILIZE PP IN
ORDER TO MOCK MITIGATE ANY
POTENTIAL COVERT NINETEEN
INFECTION. WE SET A PATH TO
BUILD A SUSTAINABLE RELIABLE
CAPABILITY THAT WOULD MOVE US
FROM A DEFENSIVE POSITION TO AN
OFFENSE OF ONE. THIS INCLUDED
THE FOLLOWING. ONE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH TRUSTED
NGOS PARTNERS VENDORS AND SEEK
DONATIONS TO SOURCE COMMODITIES.
TRUE WE WOULD IDENTIFY AND
ESTABLISH A SUSTAINABLE AND
ROUTE OR LIABLE PIPELINE OF PP
BUT ONLY FOR AND NINETY FIVE IN
SEARCH OF MASS IN ESSENCE THIS
WILL BE INVESTMENT IN A
MANUFACTURING CAPABILITY THAT
WE WOULD. THAT WOULD BE
DEDICATED TO SEE. FORMULA TO
WORK WITH FEMA AND DOD TO
SOURCE AND BRING INTO THE STATE
THE CAPABILITY TO DISINFECT AND
REPURPOSE AND NINETY FIVE MASKS.
WE WILL WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE STRATEGY WE HAVE CONTINUED
TO SOURCE THROUGH VENDORS AND
NGOS CONTINUE TO TAKE DONATIONS
FOR A NUMBER OF NECESSARY
COMMODITIES. AS WELL WE BEEN
DOING TO BE WHY THE MOTORS A
CALIFORNIA BASED COMPANY WAS
SIGNIFICANT MANUFACTURING
CAPABILITY CHINA. BEING OFTEN
IN Y. DE ABILITIES TO SOURCE ME.
IN FACT BE WHY HE HAS BEEN
PROVIDING SURGICAL MASK TO US
NOW. WHAT WITH MORE THAN THIRTY
TWO MILLION DELIVERED. THESE
MASS HAVE BEEN CRITICAL TO
HELPING US OPEN OUR STATE AGAIN.
THE OTHER PART OF THIS CONTRACT
WAS A SUSTAINABLE PIPELINE OF
SCARCE AND NINETY FIVE MASS.
THIS PORTION OF CONTRACT. IS
CONTINGENT UPON B. Y. DE
OBTAINING DIOS CERTIFICATION
THIS IS A NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION SAFETY
CERTIFICATION. WHILE WE
EXPECTED THIS UP- THIS
CERTIFICATION IN EARLY MAY
WHICH WHICH IS THE UP THE WORK
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH FEMA THE
FDA ON THIS EFFORT WE LEARNED
THAT THAT- THE CERTIFICATION
WITH WOULD NOT BE. OF PROVIDE A
MAY YOU'RE NOW. AT THE END OF
MAY OR THE FIRST WEEK IN JUNE.
IF THE CERTIFICATION IS NOT IN
CALIFORNIA GETS A 100% OF ITS
FUN BACK. THE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WAS RETURNED TO CALIFORNIA AS
OUTLINED IN THE CONTRACT. AND
THE CONTRACT HAS BEEN RELEASED.
THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CONTRACTOR CLEAR. SPECIFICALLY
OUTLINES ALL THE SAFETY
PROVISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
IN PLACE IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF CALIFORNIA. TWO HUNDRED
FORTY NINE DOLLARS AS IF HE
DIDN'T KEEP. A TIGHT LINE FOR
FIVE THREE. THAT WILL BE RE. TO
THE STATE AND IT. AS WELL IN
WORKING TO BUILD A SUSTAINABLE
PIPE. WE SAW THE ENGAGEMENT
INNOVATION MANUFACTURING POWER
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO HAVE COMPANIES RETOOL
PRODUCTION LINES TO MAKE AT
SCALE NEEDED COMMODITIES OR
SERVICES. THIS IS A SUCCESSFUL
ENDEAVOR WITH HUNDREDS OF
COMPANIES NOW PROCURING OR
PRODUCING NECESSARY ITEMS SOME
EXAMPLES INCLUDE BLOOM ENERGY
IN SAN JOSE RETOOL TO REPAIR
VENTILATORS ANHEUSER BUSCH AND
BEAR IN LOS ANGELES RETOOL TO
PRODUCE HAND SANITIZER. SAINT
JOHN NEXT AND FABRICS IN LOS
LOS ANGELES RETOOLED TO
MANUFACTURE GALLONS OF FACE
COVERINGS OAKLEY SUNGLASSES AN
ORANGE. TOOL TO PRODUCE FACE
SHIELDS VIRGIN ORBIT ROCKET- IN
LONG BEACH RETOOLED TO PRODUCE
VENTILATORS UNTRIED
MANUFACTURING GARMENT
MANUFACTURING SPECIALIZES IN
LOS ANGELES RETOOL TO PRODUCE
PLACE CLOTH FACE. MASKS AND
FACE COVERINGS AND REUSABLE
GALLONS OF AN ECCENTRIC.
THERE'S MANY OF THESE. A THIRD
PRONG IT IT OBTAINING A
CAPABILITY TO DISINFECT AND
REPURPOSE AND NINETY FIVE MASKS
THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS WITH FEMA
THE STATE LEVERAGE NEW
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY TO SAFELY
REVIEWS PP ON APRIL TWENTIETH
THE FIRST BUT TELL UNIT ARRIVED
IN BURBANK. FTA ISSUED
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION FOR
THE EMERGENCY USE OF THIS.
CRITICAL CARE DECONTAMINATION
SYSTEM FOR USE IN
DECONTAMINATING AND NINETY FIVE
RESPIRATORS THE MATTEL UNIT CAN
DECONTAMINATE ONE MASK UP TO
TWENTY TIMES THE UNIT CAN CLEAN%
TEN THOUSAND MASTER THE TIME
AND UP TO EIGHTY THOUSAND MASS
PER DAY A SECOND BUT TELL UNIT
IS NOW LOCATED IN FREMONT. TO
ASIAN CONTINUES TO BE A-
DOMESTIC PRODUCTION IS RAMPING
UP BUT IS NOT YET SUFFICIENT TO
MEET ALL THE NEEDS. AT THE SAME
TIME EXPORTS FROM CHINA
CONTINUE TO BE RESTRICTED BY
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT AND MAY
FURTHER RESTRICT IN THE FUTURE
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE FED
WE WORK TIRELESSLY TO MEET THE
TREMENDOUS ONGOING DEMAND OF
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
HOSPITAL FIRST USED. AND GO. IN
A TIME IN PROACTIVE POSSIBLE.
IT IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THAT
ALL OF THE ACTIVITY AROUND PP
HAS TAKEN AND CONTINUES TO TAKE
PLACE IN A RAPIDLY EVOLVING
DYNAMIC ENVIRONMENT. HOWEVER
THE LOGISTICS TEAM. IN THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
CONTINUES TO WORK PROCUREMENT
AND DISTRIBUTION OF P. B. AS
WELL AS BILL THE STATE'S
PREPAREDNESS TO FILL PP. DURING
FUTURE OUTBREAKS THIS STRATEGY
SUPPORTS THE RE OPENING OF
CALIFORNIA BY PROVIDING A STATE
SOLUTION TO US IMMEDIATE MET
NEEDS SB. READING UP I BLAME
FOR STATE. AND SECTORS TO
PROCURE THEIR OWN P. B. AS A
SATURDAY WE HAVE ISSUED ORDERS
FOR APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SIX MILLION AND
NINETY FIVE. MILLION OKAY
NINETY FOR A MAN SEVEN THREE
SEVEN MILLION OTHER KINDS OF
MASS FORTY ONE MILLION FACE
SHIELDS THREE OR FOUR MILLION
NIGHT LOVES SIXTY MILLION
GALLONS. FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION PAIRS OF COVERALLS
TWELVE MILLION PAIRS OF GOGGLES
TWO MILLION VINYL GLOVES ONE
POINT ONE MILLION SHOE COVERS
AND ONE MILLION- FOUGHT CAPS.
THE TOTAL COST OF THESE ITEMS.
BILLION ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE. AND SIX HUNDRED NINETY ONE
THOUSAND. AS WELL. TO HELP
MANAGE THE FURTHER AND FURTHER
THAT THE INCOMING OFFERS THE
DAY BEFORE THE GOVERNOR ISSUE
THE STATE ON ORDER WE ANNOUNCED
THE LAUNCH OF THE STATE'S
COVERT NINETEEN WEBSITE COVERT
NINETEEN DOT CA DOT GOV TO
SERVE AS ONE A ONE STOP SHOP
FOR INFORMATION A CO THE
FEDERAL RESERVE IS FOLLOWING ON
THAT KELLY US. CONTRIBUTORS
WORK. IS THE IN THE POTENTIAL
VENDORS OFFERING TO SELL
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT TO THE STATE
FOR THE COVERT NINETEEN
RESPONSE AND A LARGE DONATIONS
OFFER TO THE STATE LEADERS FROM
ALL STATE AGENCIES WERE
RECEIVING EMAILS AND CALLS
REGARDING NEW SUPPLY LINES FOR
PP BETWEEN MARCH SEVENTEENTH
AND APRIL SECOND THE STATE
CALIFORNIA RISK TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
INDIVIDUAL. CONTRIBUTION OFFERS
WITH OVER 70% OF THEM.
REPRESENTING VENDORS DURING
THIS TIME CALORIE US DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES BEGAN WORKING TOGETHER
TO BUILD AN INTERNAL SYSTEM. TO
THE INTAKE VALIDATE THAT AND
PROCURE SUPPLIES DURING A
DISASTER THIS SYSTEM WAS BUILT
WITH GENEROUS DONATION FROM
SALES FORCE AND WILL BE USED.
IN A FEW ALL FUTURE DISASTERS
FORMER CHIEF PROCUREMENT AND
STATEWIDE DONATION MANAGEMENT
OPPOSITE POINT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DONATIONS MEASURE
WAS COORDINATED ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL WITH STATE SUPPORT. THIS
NEW SYSTEM WILL ALLOW THE STATE.
MORE ACTIVE CORPORATION
DONATIONS COLLECTING DURING ALL
MAJOR DISASTERS. THE CITY
CALIFORNIA COVERT NINETEEN
MEDICAL SUPPLIES CONTRIBUTIONS
PORTAL WAS OFFICIALLY LAUNCHED
ON APRIL FOURTH. THERE'VE BEEN
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED SUBMISSIONS RECEIVED TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
SUPPLY PART CONTRIBUTIONS
PORTAL TO THIS TO THE STATE. AS
SOON AS THE SUBMISSION RECEIVED
THE VENDOR RECEIVES AN
AUTOMATIC EMAIL ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
RECEIPT OF THE SUBMISSION. THE
REQUEST IS THEN PUSHED TO THE
VETTING GROUP CONSISTING OF THE
FOLLOWING GROUPS CONTRIBUTIONS
GROUP OF VALIDATIONS GROUP. AND
A PROCUREMENT GROUP. WHAT'S THE
NOTICE OF INTEREST IS ENTERED
INTO CONTRIBUTIONS WORKING
GROUP. THE GROUP REVIEWS THE
SUBMISSION WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS OF RECEIVING DETERMINES
IF IT IS A UNIQUE SUBMISSION
HOUSE THE PERSON SUBMITTED THE
EXACT SAME INFORMATION IN THE
PAST. IF THEY HAVE FILLED OUT
THE FORMS PROPERLY IF THE
VENDOR HAS NOT PROVIDED ENOUGH
INFORMATION ABOUT THE BUSINESS
OR THE OR THE RESOURCE THEY'RE
OFFERING THEY WILL BE
DISQUALIFIED EVERY EVEN THE
MAIL AT THAT TIME IF THEY ARE.
ALL FIVE ENCOURAGE THEM TO
RESUBMIT WITH INFORMATION
REQUESTED IF THE VENDOR HAS
PROVIDED ENOUGH INFORMATION THE
CONTRIBUTIONS WORKING GROUP
WILL BIND THE VENDOR.
VALIDATION GROUP VALID THAT THE
RESOURCE WILL MEET STATE'S BEST
ASIANS. UNDER WILL RECEIVE AN
EMAIL STATING THAT THEY WILL BE
A CONTACT FOR MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THIS RESOURCE INFORMATION
REQUESTED INCLUDES BUSINESS
INFORMATION TAX ID NUMBER YOUR
BRING CORPORATION EXCEPT. IF A
RESOURCES MOVED TO THE
VALIDATION GROUP IT IS REVIEW
BY ONE OF FOUR UNITS WITHIN THE
VALIDATION GROUP CONSISTING OF
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND OR THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES OR FORTY TO REVIEW THE
MEDICAL SUPPLIES. THESE FEES
FOR UNITS ARE THE VENTILATOR
UNIT THE TESTING VALIDATION
UNIT. THE CV P. H. VALIDATION
UNIT FOR P. B. E. M. THE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT UNIT. THE
VALIDATION GROUP THEN
PRIORITIZES THEIR REVIEW OF THE
RESOURCES BASED ON WHAT THE
VENDOR SAYS. THE QUALITY
PRODUCT AND THE LEAD TIME FOR
SHIPMENT MEETING THE
PROCUREMENT GOALS EACH
VALIDATION GROUP UTILIZES
APPROPRIATE SPECIFICATIONS
CRITERIA ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR
PRODUCT LINE FOR REVIEWING
SUPPLIES AND ALL REACH OUT TO
THE VENDOR TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
COMMODITY AS REQUIRED. BASED ON
THE REVIEW THEY WILL EITHER
DISQUALIFY THE RESOURCE OR SEND
IT TO THE PROCUREMENT GROUP.
THEY WILL SEND AN EMAIL AT THE
TIME STATING THE OUTCOME OF THE
REVIEW THE PROCUREMENT GROUP.
THEN REVIEWS THE VALIDATION
GROUPS ASSESSMENT AND
PRIORITIZE THEIR REVIEW OF THE
VENDOR BASED ON THE STATE'S
GOALS AND THEY REACH OUT TO THE
VENDOR TO DISCUSS PURCHASE
TERMS. QUET MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE VENDOR. BASED ON THE
OUTCOME OF THE DISCUSSIONS THEY
WILL EITHER PER PURSUE-
RESOURCE FOR DISQUALIFY I AM
WILL SEND AN EMAIL. OF SUCH.
FACTOR AS WELL AS A COMPONENT
TO THE STATE'S ENHANCE VETTING
PROCESS WE INCORPORATED
PROCEDURES. AND ONGOING CHECKS
AND BALANCES IN REAL TIME FOR
THE PROCUREMENT GROUP TO ACCESS
AND COORDINATE WITH IN
PARTNERSHIP. WITH LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION THE US ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY. TO TRY TO
GET AS MUCH OF THESE- GROUPS AS
POSSIBLE. THIS STRATEGY IS
ALIGNED WITH THE GOVERNOR SIX
INDICATORS AND FOUR STAGES FOR
RE OPENING THE STATE. IT FOR MY
DEGREE IF WE- THE FIVE MEDICAL
HEALTH SOCIAL SERVICES. AND
TROUT. I GO TRANSPORTATION AND
A SEC CAP. HIGHER EFFORTS TO
SHOULD PP BURN RATES OF
EXISTING PP AN IMMEDIATE NEEDS
TO SUPPORT OPERATIONS THIS
STRATEGY WILL BE FURTHER
REFINED AS PP REQUIREMENTS FROM
ADDITIONAL SET INCLUDE
MANUFACTURING CONSTRUCTION FOOD
SERVICE EXCEPT FOR A INCLUDING
GOVERNMENT BY THE WAY. IT WILL
BE ABLE TO AT THE RECALL OF
THIS BODY- MOVE OVER FORTY
THOUSAND- SURGICAL MASKS SO
THAT THIS BODY. COULD MOVE
FORWARD WITH OUR FUTURE-
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS THESE
PROJECTIONS ARE ALSO BASED ON
WHAT WE UNDERSTAND TO BE
FEDERAL EFFORTS TO DIRECTLY
PROVIDE P. PETER HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES. STING HEALTHCARE
DISTRIBUTORS AS WELL AS TO
DIRECTION RENTS THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES.
DISTRIBUTION OF STRATEGY FOR
STATE PARK CONTACT A CONTRACT
AND NINETY FIVES PROCEDURE
MASSING CLOTH MASS INCLUDES A
PROCESS FOR PRIORITIZING AND
DISTRIBUTING PP TO HEALTH AND
NON HEALTH SECTORS DURING THE
EMERGENCY PHASE. THE SECOND
PHASE INCLUDE. AGREEMENT FOR
THOSE SECTORS TO PURCHASE THEIR
OWN OUR DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES IS WORKING ON BUILDING
UP OF THE CAPABILITY FOR A
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER ENTITIES
TO IDENTIFY PROCURE PEE PEE ON
THEIR OWN. LAST WE WILL PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES UP LOWERS LAWYERS ON
THE TYPE AND USE OF PP AND THE
AND UP AND HOW THAT PP ALIGN
WITH RE OPENING ROADMAP.
STRATEGIES AN EXISTING RESEARCH
PROJECTS AND NEEDS. IN CLOSING
LET ME JUST REITERATE A FEW
POINTS. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
RESPONDING TO COVERT NINETEEN
SINCE MID TO LATE JANUARY. WHEN
THE REPATRIATION EFFORTS OF US
CITIZENS TOOK PLACE TO OUR
STATE. THIS ALLOWED US TO
ENGAGE IN ADVANCE PLANNING
EFFORTS WITH LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO OPT TO
APPROPRIATELY MANAGE THE RATE
OF INFECTION. IN RELATE. THE
OTHER SIX GIVEN THE POPULATION
AREA AND SIZE OF CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN THE ONGOING GLOBAL
SHORTAGE OF PP CALIFORNIA HAS
STILL BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE AND
DISTRIBUTE NOW FORTY SIX
MILLION AND NINETY FIVE MASS
OVER THIRTY TWO MILLION
SURGICAL MASKS OR PROCEDURE
MASS OVER ONE MILLION GALLONS
OVER FOUR MILLION FACE SHIELDS
AND NEARLY SIXTEEN MILLION
GLOVE SETS. ALSO INCLUSIVE
CALIPHATE BOBBING ITS OWN
DIRECT SUPPLY CHAIN OF
PROTECTIVE MASS. FOR THE SHORT
TERM AND THE LONG TERM IT WILL
BE NECESSARY TO ALLOW FOR THE
RE OPENING OF OUR STATE. WHO
MAY NOT RECEIVE UTILIZE
PROTECTIVE MASK ON A CONTINUAL
BASIS BUT MAY REQUIRED. POST
OVER NINETEEN VARMINT. GIVEN
THE TREMENDOUS INTEREST IN THE
STATUS OF PP ALLOCATION AND TO
ENSURE FOR TRANSPARENCY WE
ESTABLISHED TWO SECTIONS ON THE
COVERT NINETEEN WEBSITE.
DEDICATED TO PP THE FIRST
SECTION CALLED COUNTY MAPS
ALLOWS THE READER TO SCROLL
OVER THEIR RESPECTIVE COUNTY
AND SEE DATA ANALYTICS
ASSOCIATE WITH COVERT NINETEEN
CASES HOSPITALS AND THE QUAL
CALL ONE QUANTITY OF PP BE
DISTRIBUTED IN THAT COUNTY.
THIS CALL PP REQUEST AND
DISTRIBUTION PROCESS AND IS
DESIGNED TO DESCRIBE HOW TO
SECURE PP FROM THE STATE'S
STOCKPILE. FOR THE VARIOUS
SECTORS THAT MAY. EXAMPLES OF
THOSE SECTORS INCLUDE OFTEN%
MEDICAL CHILD CARE SENIOR CARE
AND ASSISTED LIVING AGRICULTURE
FARMWORKERS SCHOOLS TRANSIT AND
TRANSPORTATION GROCERS IN FOOD
SERVICE AND MANUFACTURING. THIS
DESCRIBES HOW TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM THE PROCESS TO ALLOW
REQUEST TO OBTAIN COMMODITIES.
BOB THERE'S BEEN NO MONEY THAT
THE STATE HAS LOST IN ANY OF
THESE EMERGENCY PROCUREMENT FOR
TRANSACTIONS TODAY. THE STATE
HAS NO MONEY IN ANY OF THESE
TRANSACTIONS OR PERFORMANCE TO
DATE AND THAT HAS BEEN REQUIRED
AS AN UNDERTAKING DURING THE
COVERT NINETEEN RESPONSE. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAVE STOCK
AND A NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL
CHECKS AND BALANCE INCLUDE.
WITH OUR DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY FBI AND US ATTORNEY
OFFICE. WITHOUT AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THESE COMMENTS SUCH A
COMPLEX. OF VERY COMPLEX VERY
ELABORATE- FAST MOVING AND
DYNAMIC ASYMMETRICAL EVENT-
THAT IS REALLY REQUIRED ALL
HANDS ON DECK. IN A AND I CAN'T
BE PROBLEM. OF THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO HAVE THEY HAVE
DEDICATED THEMSELVES IN THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER UNDER
TREMENDOUS CONDITIONS WORKING
LITERALLY TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TO
BE ABLE TO SOURCE A CORNERSTONE
OF OUR ABILITY TO ON AND THAT
PP- OF. WITHOUT ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. DAY THANK YOU
DIRECTOR FOR THE UPDATE- ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF YOU HAVE A
QUESTION GOING TO POP. RIGHT
GET MISTER PATTERSON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE-
OPPORTUNITY ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS- YOU MAY HAVE
ANSWERED THIS I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE. WHERE ARE WE GETTING OUR
IN NINETY FIVE MASKS NOW. THE
HOW MANY DO WE HAVE AND DO WE
KNOW ESSENTIALLY WHERE THEY ARE.
SO ON THE CAKE THE FIRST PART
OF THAT WE GET OUR AND NINETY
FIVE MASS CURRENTLY FROM A
VARIETY OF SOURCES- SOME ARE
BEING SOURCED FROM- OVERSEAS
ASIA MARKET- WHERE WE CAN
SQUEEZE OUT. OF SMALL ORDERS OF
AND NINETY FIVE OPPOSED TO THE
BORDERS NOW ARE COMING OUT ARE
SMALL AND WHEN I SAY SMALL I'M
TALKING IN THE- LESS THAN
MILLION NUMBER MORE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS- THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME OFFER. THE
MARKET IS CHANGING A LITTLE BIT
WHERE WE CAN. GET ALL OF. TO BE
R. THERE'S A THERE'S COMPANY IS
NOW. A WORKING ON OFTEN
PURPOSING AND NINETY FIVE BASS-
BUT BUT EVEN. WITH BOTH IT IS A
PRINCE CAN ONLY USE. AND THE
ONLY PROVIDE AS WITH ARIEL. YOU
WE HAVE POOREST AS PART OF OUR
AGREEMENT WITH WHY THE TO SOME
A HUNDRED MILLION AND NINETY
FIVE SOME. OF AND THE
CONTRACTORS UPON THE ABILITY TO
GET THOSE MATT. IN A VERY
SPECIFIC SET OF TIME FRAMES ARE
AND CAN BE CANCELED AT ANY TIME
WE LONGER NEED THE MATH MASKS.
THE MASS WE ALSO GET. FROM FEMA
FEMA HAS BEEN AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER IN MY COMMENTS. 30% OF
THE OPERATION- BRIDGE GOES TO
FEMA FOR- PURPOSING IN THE
NATIONAL STOCKPILE. AND WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO GET A LITTLE BIT
SAID I'M TALKING LIKE IN THE
ONE TO TWO MILLION. OVER THE
COURSE OF TIME AS SOON AS WE
GET THE P. THESE KIND OF PP.
MASKS OF ALL SORTS AND TYPES.
WE TURN THEM AROUND AND PUSH
THEM BACK OUT BECAUSE WE ARE SO
LET THE DEFICIT. IN UNFILLED
NEED FOR MASKS. RIGHT NOW I
THINK IN THE STOCKPILE WE HAVE-
BECAUSE WE JUST GOT A BIG
SHIPMENT. OF THE WHY THE
SURGICAL MASKS- BY THE WAY THAT
THE THAT THE TWO PARTS OF THE
B. Y. DE CONTRACT. ONE WAS AND
NINETY FIVE MASS. SUSTAINABLE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION UP ALIVE
AND THE OTHER. WAS SURGICAL
MASKS. JUST LIKE THE ONE I'M
WEARING. ARE WHICH WAS A FIFTY
MILLION A MONTH. THEY WERE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY- ACCELERATE GOES IN
AND MOVE THEM TO US ALMOST TWO
WEEKS IN ADVANCE OF. THE
EXPECTED- OF CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS WHICH ALLOWED US
TO PUSH THOSE HARD INTO THE
COMMUNITY. THE SUSE WE GET THE
MAN WE TURN THEM AROUND. THIS
WEEKEND WE PUSH POST ELEVEN
MILLION MASS OUT ALL DIFFERENT
SORTS OF SECTOR FROM
TRANSPORTATION TO SCHOOLS TO.
HEALTH CARE. TO NAME IT- RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE ABOUT A MILLION AND
NINETY FIVES SITTING IN OUR
WAREHOUSE- WE'RE EXPECTING US
TO SHIP ME TODAY. THE ABSENT I
JUST. WITH WITH THIS PP. HOW
HOW ARE YOU CAN SEE WHERE IT
GOES THE- WAY THIS WORKS IS
THAT. THE REQUEST FOR MADE UP
THROUGH A COUPLE DIFFERENT
WAYS. MOST OF THE REQUEST TO
COME THROUGH THE MEDICAL HEALTH
SYSTEM. FOR ANY NINETY FIVES IN
CIRCLES WHICH ARE PREDOMINATELY
USED FOR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AND FIRST RESPONDERS. THEY GO
TO THEIR MEDICAL HEALTH
COORDINATOR AT THE- OPERATIONAL
AREA OR COUNTY LEVEL. THEY
THEN- TYPICALLY THEY HAVE ALL
THE WAREHOUSE THERE'D BE TRYING
TO FILL THOSE BUT IN THIS CASE
IT COMES RIGHT UP TO THE STATE
BECAUSE THEY THEY DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING IN THE WAREHOUSE. AND
WHAT IS YOUR HE DID EIGHT FILL
OUT THE WAREHOUSE IS. DOWN TO
THE- PUBLIC HEALTH. OF THE
COUNTY. WITH THE PUSH THEM OUT
TO THE VARIOUS ENTITIES THAT
MAKE THE REQUEST. YOU CAN SEE
WE'RE ALL THOSE GO BY GOING TO-
THE- COUNTY MAP THAT I
MENTIONED- ON THE COVERT. DOT
NINETY WITH A COVER NINETEEN
DOT CA DOT GOV WEBSITE. AND ALL
ON THERE YOU CAN GO WITH THE
COUNTY AND YOU CAN SEE HOW MANY
SPECIFICALLY HOW MANY PEOPLE
USE HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED OUT.
OUR ONLY LEVEL. THE COUNTIES
KEEP THE TRACK OF WHO'S IN NEED
OF THOSE IN WHERE THESE THOSE
GO- AND YOU KNOW LIKE I SAY
RIGHT NOW WELL THE BIG THING IS
WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE STILL IN A
VERY. AND COME ON THE US. DOING
MUCH BETTER ON THE SURGICAL
MASK- BECAUSE THE SUSTAINABLE
RELIABLE PIPELINE THAT WE PUT
IN PLACE IS DELIVERED AND NOW
WE'RE BEING ABLE TO PUSH THOSE
OUT TO THE COMMUNITY AS WE
SPEAK. THANK YOU UP RESPECTED
IN NINETY FIVE. MASKS AND THE
B. Y. THE CONTRACT ARE YOU
CONCERNED THAT THEY MAY NOT BE.
A CERTIFIED AND IF THEY ARE NOT
CERTIFIED IN A TIMELY FASHION
TO HAVE A BACK UP PLAN FOR
PROVIDING THE ADDITIONAL MASKS
THAT THE B. Y. DE CONTRACT FOR
THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION THANK
YOU- SO. WE WITHIN THE
PROVISIONS OF THE CONTRACT-
SPECIFICALLY STATED AS A
CONDITION. ALL IS THAT THE- THE
VENDOR NEEDS TO PROVIDE A NYLON
FDA CERTIFIED. AND NINETY FIVE
MASS THAT MEANS THAT THEY- IT'S
A COME UPON THEM TO OBTAIN THAT
AND I'LL CERTIFICATION. THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENED IN MAY WE-
EXPECTED THEM TO HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GET THAT AND NINETY FIVE-
NOW CERTIFICATION IN MAY- THEY
HAVE- PROVISIONAL CERTIFICATION
BY MY ALSO- BUT- IN A SECONDARY
PALM REVIEW BY UNDER.
LABORATORY ON BEHALF OF THE FDA
AND I ALSO- THE WE HAVE THEY
HAVE THEY FOUND SOME PROBLEMS
IN THE DOCUMENTATION. WITH
REGARDS TO- THE NEED TO IN A
MOVE THAT THE APPLICATION FOR
ON THE SPEC SHEETS. MCCURRY BUT
ACTUALLY I AM. THERE ARE THE
WORKING ON THAT ACTION PLAN AND
WEEKS BACK FULLY EXPECTED BE
ABLE TO GET THE CERTIFICATION
OF THE PRODUCT MATERIALS IN
CELLS HAD ALREADY BEEN.
DETERMINED BY THE OPTION OF
BEING OF QUALITY AND WE'RE
ASKING FOR THE HIGHEST QUALITY
AND NINETY FIVE MASS THE ROAD
BY THE WAY STE YOU KNOW. A
VARIETY OF IT THE FILES FROM
AND NINETY IS THAT RUN FROM
SIXTY FIVE CENTS. TO AND NINETY
FIVE THE RUN FOR THREE DOLLARS
AND TWENTY. IN THE MARKET. SO
THERE ARE. TIMES IT AND FIVE.
AND THESE ARE ONES THAT WE WERE.
HI SCHOOL. CASE OF MAY NOT
MEETING THE MAY REQUIRE. THAT'S
WHY. THEY HAD TO IMMEDIATELY
THAT TO OUR TOO I FIFTY FOUR
MILLION. BACK BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT MEET THAT- IF. WE DO NOT
HAVE- THE SECOND. ONE FAILED-
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE AT WITH A
NUMBER OF OTHER STATES. AND
PERMITS WE ARE COULD TO
ACTIVELY SOURCE THROUGH OUR
FIRST STRATEGY PRONG STRATEGY
AND THIS IS WHY WE DID A THREE
PRONGED STRATEGY. JUST AS A
REMINDER THE FIRST PROBLEM WAS
WORKING WITH NGOS AND OUR
NORMAL VENDOR COMMUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO- PROVIDED- AND NINETY
FIVE THE SECOND ONE WAS THROUGH
A PIPELINE SECURE PIPELINE AND
THE THIRD WAS. THE PATEL UNIT
WHERE WE WERE DISINFECTING- AT
AND RECERTIFIED THOSE MASKS FOR
USE WE HAVE ENTERED INTO
AGREEMENTS WITH SEVERAL.
HUNDRED HOSPITALS NOW I'VE-
GOT. NUMBER TODAY. ARE THAT ARE%
WORKING WITH BEING ABLE TO
COLLECT THEIR THEIR AND NINETY
FIVE RISE USE THAN NINETY FIVE
MASS. AND MOVE THEM FORWARD
THROUGH THE DISINFECTION
PROCESS THAT WILL. THIS AFFECT
UP TO EIGHTY THOUSAND A DAY BUT-
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT. WE HAVE
TO SEE A LITTLE BIT OF A OF A
SLOWING STILL NOT STILL NOT
COMPLETELY MET. BUT A LITTLE
BIT OF A SLOWING IN THE AND
NINETY FIVE REQUIREMENTS BY THE
HOSPITAL BECAUSE- THE MAJOR
PROVIDERS. THAT HAVE BEEN
SOURCE THROUGH THE AIR BRIDGE
OPERATION AIRBRIDGE ARE
STARTING TO PROVIDE THAT THOSE
COMMODITIES DIRECTLY THE
HOSPITALS. AND DESERVE
COMPANIES LIKE MCKESSON AND
CARDINAL THE NORMAL COMPANIES
THAT. THESE HOSPITALS ALREADY
WORK WITH SO A NUMBER OF
FACTORS AGAIN IN THIS IN THE
MARKET SPACE. OUR OUR CONTINUE
TO EVOLVE AND SHIFT- WE ALSO
ARE STARTING TO SEE A LITTLE
BIT OF A DOMESTIC PRODUCTION
COME AROUND- SO OUR OUR PLAN IS
THAT WE WILL THEN. EVENT AND
USE SOME OF THE OTHER PRONG
APPROACHES WILL CONTINUE TO USE
THOSE PRODUCT PURCHASE IT'S
NOT. IT'S NOT- CONSECUTIVE ITS
CONCURRENTLY- BUT WE THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT AS WE WENT FORWARD
IN THE EVENT THAT WE WOULDN'T
DOUBT OF THE OLD MAN- UP A-
FORCED TO GET. THOSE BRAND HI
YEAH AND I FIVE SEVEN ATTIC
WE'RE- WE'RE COFFIN. THAT WILL
BE ABLE BILLS. ONE MORE.
QUESTION AT IT SAID TO PUT ARE
THERE ALL. SIMILAR NO BILL TO
LOOK THE NO BID IN LARGE STE.
URGENCY CONTRACTS THE STATE HAS
ENTERED INTO THAT WE DO NOT
KNOW ABOUT OR HAVE NOT BEEN
PUBLICLY DISCLOSED I BELIEVE
ALL OF THE CONTRACTS THAT- THAT
THAT THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER HAS. ENTERED INTO HAVE
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE AND YOU
KNOW- THERE COULD BE OUT THERE
COULD BE A OF. THE WORK. I NOW
WE ARE HAPPY CONSTANTLY TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN THEIR ARE BUT I WILL
TELL YOU THAT I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW OF ANY LARGE- PROCUREMENTS
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE- I FOR
ALL THE THING IS MENTIONED.
WE'VE BUILT A MUCH. EVEN LIVE.
EFFORT AND AN THAT AND THE AND
MARKETS OFFICE CHANGE A LITTLE
BIT ONE. ATTACK AND I'M THE
CHAIRS INDULGENCE. OUR THERE
ARE ANY OTHER CONTRACTS WHERE
THERE IS TAXPAYER MONEY-
FLOATING AROUND OUT THERE- IN
JEOPARDY OF NON PERFORMING
CONTRACTS. I'M A LITTLE THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION LITTLE. CAN
YOU CLARIFY FLOATING AROUND OUT
THERE WELL AGAIN YOU HAVE WE
HAVE MARKED THE THESE
CONTRACTS- AND YOUR MONEY IS
SENT IT'S OUT THERE AND YET YOU
ARE YOU HAVE CONTRACTS THAT ARE
IN THE MIDST NON PERFORMED. IN
THE WORDS IT COULD. NOW FEAR
THAT MIGHT HAVE FAILED IS LIKE
B. Y. DE. WELL CONTRACT OF
COURSE HAS EIGHT EVERY VENDOR
IF THE CONTRACTOR OF COURSE- IN
SOME FORM OR FASHION- COULD
POTENTIALLY. DELIVERY OF THEIR
SERVICES- WE ARE BUILT IN THE
ALL OF THE CONTRACTS OF
REQUIREMENTS- FOR IMMEDIATE
TERMINATION. AND OUTSIDE OF
ONLY A COUPLE OF CONTRACTS. AND
REALLY IT'S ONLY A HANDFUL OF
CONTRACTS THAT WE ACTUALLY MOVE
MONEY FORWARD ALL THE MONEY
THAT HAS ALL THE CONTRACTS THAT
HAVE BEEN AND WE'VE ENTERED
INTO HAVE ALL BEEN A PAY WHEN
SEVE MILITARY SO WE INSPECT.
MADE THE LIST- THEY MEET EVERY
REQUIREMENTS AND IT'S THE NEXT
FORTY FIVE DAYS OR US LIKE THAT
THAT THAT THAT WE HAVEN'T
PLAYED THAT THROUGH THE NORMAL
PERFORMER PROFITS THAT WE WERE.
IT WAS ONLY A- VERY. HE'S VERY
LARGE COUPLE THESE LARGE-
CONTRACTS THAT WERE NECESSARY
TO MOVE FORWARD EARLY ON- THAT
WE ACTUALLY MOVED- MONEY FOR
WORK AND- AND AS A SAID- THE-
THE ACTUAL MONEY- ONLY MONEY
THAT ACTUALLY EXCHANGED INTO-
THE- WHERE WE'RE GETTING A
PRODUCT BACK- THAT WE HAVE NOT
CANCEL OR- DIDN'T YOU MONEY IS
THE BE WAITING. I'M FINISHED I
PUSH IT A MARK WANT TO SAY
PERSONAL YOU KNOW SOME OF US
REMEMBERS. A WHO SERVE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ALSO ON THE-
AUDIT COMMITTEE AND ALL WE HAVE
HAD SOME. LOCAL CONCERNS ABOUT-
DIVISIONS DEPARTMENTS IT'S
AFTER WITH WITH IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT I PERSONALLY APPRECIATE
VERY VERY MUCH WHAT YOU HAVE
DONE. AND YOU HAVE ALSO BEEN
VERY RESPONSIVE VERY HELPFUL
WITH RESPECT TO DISTRICT IN THE
PEOPLE HAVE CONCERNS WE PASS
ALONG YOUR YOUR STAFF VERY
QUICK TO RESPOND. AND WE DO A
VERY VERY GOOD JOB I NEXT THE
WIND. AND I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH MARK THANK YOU FOR. MY OUT.
MEDINA YEAH. THANK YOU. THIS
HERE TODAY I REPRESENT OF THE
SIXTY FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
WHICH INCLUDES MARINO VALLEY
WE'RE MARCH AIR FORCE BASE IS
LOCATED. IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
AND I AM VERY HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT THE SITUATION REGARDING-
THE PROTECTIVE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT HAS GOTTEN
BETTER. IN THE IN THE FIRST FEW
DAYS. OF THE STATE AT HOME
ORDERS THE INLAND EMPIRE.
SPECIFICALLY RIVERSIDE COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY ON. ON MARCH
TWENTY FOURTH HAD ASKED FOR
MASS AND THE ADMINISTRATION
POINTED OUT THAT THEY HAD
RECEIVED THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND MASS WHEN
IN REALITY RIVERSIDE COUNTY
ONLY RECEIVED SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY MASS OF THE THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE. THOUSAND THE
MINISTRY SAID RECEIVE- THE
MEMBER OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
CAUCUS I KNOW THAT. WITH THE
SITUATION THAT RIVERSIDE COUNTY
FACE WAS NOT TOO DIFFERENT FROM
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY AS WELL.
SO I I'D I'D LIKE TO HEAR IF
YOU WOULD. WHAT WERE THE
CHALLENGES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
I UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT IT
WAS TO GET. THE EQUIPMENT BUT
WHAT WERE THE CHALLENGES IN THE
DISTRIBUTION OF BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE- RECEIVE SOMEONE
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE INLAND
EMPIRE WE'RE NOT. THANKS FOR
THE QUESTION AND LET ME JUST
SAY THAT. CONCEIVABLY ALL IT
COULD BE TRUE AND I DON'T HAVE
THE SPECIFICS IN FRONT OF ME
FOR THAT CASE BUT I WILL TELL
YOU THAT. WE. WE COLLECTIVELY
ALL OF US HERE. DEAL WITH
PRETTY EXTENSIVE DISASTER
OPERATIONS EVERY YEAR IT'S
ALWAYS A ONE TEAM ONE FIGHT
EFFORT THE LEGISLATURE WAS THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALL WORKING
TOGETHER. TYPICALLY WE'VE GOT
TRIED AND TRUE. SYSTEMS THAT WE
USE PARTICULAR IN THE AREA OF
LOGISTICS MANAGEMENT AND
COORDINATION AND DISTRIBUTION
RESOURCE ALLOCATION. TYPICALLY
WE DO UP WHERE WE'VE GOT EVEN
YOU KNOW A REGIONAL DISASTER
MAYBE IT'S SEVERAL COUNTIES. IN
THIS ONE HOWEVER. WE HAD ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES EVERY CITY
IN THOSE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
EVERY SECTOR WITHIN THOSE
CITIES IN THOSE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES DEMANDING. AP UP IN A
IN A IN A IN A FORMAT WHERE WE
HAD VERY LIMITED AMOUNTS TO GO
AROUND CONCEIVABLY IT COULD
HAVE BEEN THAT THEY MADE THE
ORDER OF THREE HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE WE DELIVERED IT MAYBE WE
DID WE COURSE CORRECTED I DO
KNOW THAT IN THE CASE OF
RIVERSIDE AT THE SAME TIME WE
WERE ACTIVELY TRYING TO MOVE TO
FIELD HOSPITALS INTO THE REGION
INTO INTO RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY- THERE WAS A LOT
OF COMMODITY MOVEMENT GOING IN
THE RIVER SIDE. AND I WILL JUST
BE THE CA THE BAND YOU KNOW OF
THESE BIG AS ON AND IT WASN'T
FROM OF THEM PURPOSE THAT.
COULD BE BACK IN TELL YOU WE
PUSHED A LOT IN A RIVER CAL.
OBVIOUSLY UPON WHAT THE NEED
ARE HOWEVER. ON BALANCE LET ME
JUST SAY. UNDER AND AGAIN I
NEED TO LOOK AT THIS CASE
SPECIFICALLY BUT UNDER THESE
KIND OF CONDITIONS. THERE ARE
MANY JURISDICTIONS THAT
REQUESTED QUITE A BIT. BUT
BECAUSE OF THE SCARCITY REASONS
WE HAD THE TRIAGE AND
PRIORITIZE. WHO WAS GOING TO
GET STUFF AND WHO WAS IT. SO I
I'VE I'VE I'VE I GUESS I WAS
THEM APOLOGIZE IF THERE IS IF
THERE WAS SOMETHING THERE THAT.
DIDN'T WORK QUITE RIGHT BUT I
WILL LOOK INTO AND I ASSURE
YOU. THAT IT WASN'T DONE IN A
IN A IN A FORM OF. PURPOSELY
NOT PROVIDING IT IT COULD HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF DIFFERENT REASONS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWER AND-
YEAH IT JUST SEEMS LIKE ARE
PART OF THE STATE. WAS AND-
RECEIVING- THE EQUIPMENT WHEN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE'S WORK
SO THANK YOU. WELCOME. YOU'RE
GONNA AFTER QUESTIONS OF THEM
ALL RIGHT OKAY. THEN I'VE GOT A
I'VE GOT A COUPLE QUESTIONS SO-
CAN GOING FROM THE MOST IS
SPECIFIC TO. MORE BRIDES AND SO
I THINK I LIKE EVERYONE HERE
I'M VERY RELIEVED TO HEAR YOUR
AFFIRMATION THAT NO TAXPAYER
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN LOST AND- THE
X. AT THE CONTROLS THAT EXIST
HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE. AS YOU
SAID BLUE FLAME THAT WITH A
CAUTIONARY. IT SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS- FOR A CONTRACT OF
THAT SIZE NOW WHO IS THE SITE
SIGNATORY WHO WOULD BE THE
SIGNING AUTHORITY ON A
CONTRACTOR THAT SIZE SO
TYPICALLY- YOU KNOW WE DELEGATE
UNDER WHAT WE WHAT WE USE IN
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY PLAN IS
UP- COLUBER SUPPORT FUNCTION
EIGHTEEN OF THEM DIFFERENT
AGENCIES ARE MEN'S HAVE THE
PROPER. SPELLING FOR MEETING
THE RECALL. IN THIS IT'S ESF
SEVEN WHICH IS RESOURCE IN
COMMODITY MANAGEMENT. THE FORTY
REST WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES IN THIS CASE
IT WOULD BE THAT- YOU KNOW THE
DIRECTOR OR HIS DESIGNATE OR
DOES IT ME- CLEARLY VALVE THAT
SAID- AND IN A WAY THAT GOES
IT. DEPENDS ON ON WHERE THE RAT
IF INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAM
IT'S IN THE FIELD THEY MAY BE
DELEGATED A CERTAIN NUMBER OF A
FORTY STEP TO PROCURE. OF THESE
BIG BIG CONTRACTS THOUGH- AND
IT WAS ONLY A FEW OF THEM IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE EVEN IS AS
COMPLEX THIS WAS.
ALL- DISCUSSED- WITH ME AND-
WITH THE DIRECTOR OF THE GS-
AND WITH A PARTNER WITH THE
SECOND OF OUR GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS WITH THE WITH THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. DIRECTORS THE PAGE
BECAUSE THESE WERE ALL THREE
MEDICALLY NECESSARY DEVICES AND
SO WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE WE'RE
ALL SET. AT LEAST IN THE OF B.
E. R. THE AGREEMENT IT WAS. A
ONE OF YOU KNOW THE WAY THAT
THAT WAS ALL COME THAT WAS ME
THE ONES WERE DONE WITHIN THE
PRO AND IN THE CASE OF THE CASE
REBEL FLAME. I'VE WAS TO THE
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT L.
SERVICES. PACKAGE AND I THINK
THERE'S BEEN SOME RELUCTANCE
WHICH THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
EXPLAINED ABOUT THAT THE
WILLINGNESS IN THERE THE
REASONS. FOR THE RESIDENTS TO
RELEASE SOME OF THESE CONTRACTS
AROUND PP. I THINK I HEARD YOU
CORRECTLY RESPONDING TO MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTION YOU SAID
NOW ALL OF THE CONTRACTS HAVE
BEEN MADE PUBLIC AND HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
CORRECT I. AS THE MY KNOWLEDGE.
CAN I WANT PARKING FOR ONE
THING THEM. THERE WAS ONLY ONE
CONTRACT BILL THAT WE
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO HOLD ON
RELEASED. FOR THE REASON. THAT
I SORT OF MY BEFORE BUT THIS
WAS BE ID CONTRA AND IT HAD TO
DO PREDOMINATELY WITH. IT WAS
SUCH A CRITICAL. CRITICAL LOOK
PIPELINE OF ASSETS TO US. WE
HAD- A CASE WHERE WE
SPECIFICALLY WENT TO A
CALIFORNIA BASED COMPANY THAT
WAS ONE OF THE REASONS WE
APPROACH THEM WE COULD REACH
OUT AND- AND LITERALLY TOUCH
THEM WHICH WAS AN IMPORTANT.
PIECE IN OUR VETTING- BE HAVE A
MASSIVE MANUFACTURING
CAPABILITY IN CHINA AND THAT
THEY WERE ALREADY RE PURPOSING.
TO BUILD OUT AND THEY WERE WAY
AHEAD OF THE GAME. ALL THE BILL
ABOUT PP AND THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO MATERIALS LET ME BE CLEAR.
THESE SURGICAL MASKS. ANYBODY
CAN MAKE FOR THE MOST PART- TO
THE DEGREE AND NINETY FIVE
REQUIRE A CERTAIN TYPE OF
MATERIAL A CERTAIN KIND OF
THING THAT FILTERS SURGICALLY
REQUIRED MASKS ONLY OF A COUPLE
PLACES IN THE WORLD YOU CAN
ACTUALLY GET THE MATERIALS AND
SO EIGHT HI ONE IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WITH THE RESOURCES WE
HAD A PIPE ONE OF THOSE
COURSES. SO YES THIS AGREEMENT
WE STARTED WORKING ALL OF THE
BILL THIS WHAT WE FELT WAS JUST
REALLY A GREAT CONTRACT AND TO
BE ABLE TO. SUSTAIN THIS
MATERIAL. TO BACK THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT- LAW N. B. Y. B. OF
WAS BEING BESIEGED BY NOT ONLY
A NUMBER OF OTHER STATES.
EMBASSIES BY A NUMBER OF OTHER
COUNTRIES AND WE DIDN'T KNOW
QUITE FRANKLY EXACTLY HOW MUCH
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAD
PROMISED TO LIKE BRAZIL AND
FRANCE ITALY AND ALL THESE
OTHER COUNTRIES ABOUT GIVING PP
WE KNEW THAT CHINA WAS BREAKING
DOWN AND STOPPING.
MANUFACTURING IN THEIR COUNTRY
WE KNEW THAT THE VIRUS OUTBREAK
IN ONE HAD ONLY DECIMATED THE
THEIR MANUFACTURING CAPABILITY
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE COULD GO TO
WORK. THERE'S ALL THESE
COUNTRIES ALL THE STUFF THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN PROMISED AND THEN
HERE COMES CALIFORNIA. COMES
AROUND THE SIDE CORNER HERE ON
A SIDE TACKLE AND SETS UP THIS.
CONTRACT FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION MASKED A MONTH. AND
THAT WAS- ARE CONCERNED THAT IT
WOULD BE INTERRED WIEN OR SHUT
DOWN- IF WE PROVIDED TOO MUCH
OF A INFORMATION. OUR INTENTION
WAS ALWAYS TO RELEASE THE
CONTRACT WITH A VERY OFTEN IN
THE CONTRACT. BUT IT WAS ONE OF
THE THINGS FROM SECURITY
SPECTER WE JUST WANTED TO WAIT.
AND CERTAINLY YOU KNOW IT
BECAME YOU KNOW I'M A BIG DEAL-
AND- AND- AT IN IN THE END ONCE
THE MASK STARTED ROLLING IN-
AND WE KNEW THAT THE PIPELINE
WAS. SUFFICIENT WE KNEW THAT-
WE CANGET IT THROUGH CUSTOMS
WE KNEW THAT THE PLANES WOULD
WORK WE KNEW ALL THAT STUFF
WOULD HAPPEN. WE FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND REALLY SEE THAT
THE CONTRACT ALL THE REST OF
THEM HOWEVER. WERE WELL I THINK
WE'RE JUST READ IT THERE WAS NO
PROVISION OF US HOLDINGANY OF
THOSE BACK. UNDER SAID THAT
HELPS IT YES. ALSO IN THIS
CHALLENGE IS GO TO BE WITH US
FOR SOME TIME TO CALM. AND THE
BILL LIKE KNOWLEDGE THAT A
SUFFICIENT SUPPLY OF PP IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO BEING
ABLE TO RE OPEN THE STATE AND
IS A KIND OF ME. YOU SPOKE. A
BUNCH ABOUT THE WORK BEEN DONE
TO SOURCE SUPPLIERS. ON WHAT IF
ANYTHING HAVE WE DONE TO TRY TO
ENROLL SOME OF OUR GOVERNMENT
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
CAPACITY. TO TRY TO PAY THAT
DOT TO MANUFACTURING
PARTICULARLY THAT THE AND
NINETY FIVE MASKS THAT ARE SO
CRITICAL IN IN SUCH SUPPLY.
YEAH HOUSE THERE'S A COMPANY
THAT. THIS IS AGAIN EVEN EVEN
THE COMPANIES AND NINETY- THREE
AM WHICH IS THE- WHICH WHICH WE
ALL KNOW HEARD ABOUT THERE ARE
STILL HAVING TROUBLE SOURCING
MATERIALS AND BEING ABLE TO
DELIVER IN LARGE QUANTITIES.
PLUS IN THEIR CASE- THEY HAVE-
MAKE COMMITMENTS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FIRST AND FOREMOST.
OF WHICH IS BEEN CHALLENGING
FOR US BUT EVEN HONEYWELL AND
THEN THE COMPANY IN ARIZONA.
VERY SMALL QUANTITIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- I WANT TO GET MY
LIST HERE BECAUSE- THERE IS ONE
COMPANY- CALLED THE- AND
VOIGTS. AD BOOK. IT'S A- RETAIL
DISPLAY COMPANY SINCE SANTA
CLARA LAW AND IT IS BEING
RETOOLED- TO PRODUCE ANY NINE
AND NINETY FIVE MASKS SB DO
HAVE- YOU HAVE A STANDING PO
WITH US IF THEY CAN GET AND I
ARE. IN WHICH THEY'VE APPLIED
YOU AND THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
THAT PROCESS THEY'VE GOT A
STEAMY PO WITH US AS SOON AS
THEY GET THAT NOT ARE STRICTLY
XIN WILL BE FIRST IN LINE TO BE
TO GET. I'M SO. WE'RE OUT. JUST
LIKE YOU KNOW. THE FOLKS AT
OAKLEY WHO LITERALLY OR MAKING
SUNGLASSES AND NOW THEY'RE
MAKING FACE SHIELDS AND WE
MERELY THE P. OVER THAT WITH
THEM AND WE'RE GETTING- YOU
KNOW MILLIONS OFFICIALS FROM
THEMSELVES WHERE WE CAN HOW
CALIFORNIA SO INNOVATIVE OF
COURSE WE HAVE SUCH GREAT
CAPABILITY- USING OUR BY
ATTACK- KELLY I JUST RECENTLY
CAME UP WITH RESERVE AARON AND-
POTENTIAL MEDICATION. FOR KOBE
BABY KNOW DONE HEARING. WE'VE
BEEN WORK VERY CLOSE WITH THEM-
AND THIS IS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THE GOVERNOR DID BRING
TOGETHER. A CONSORTIUM OF.
BUSINESS LEADERS AND
ORGANIZATIONS WE'VE GOT WEB
PORTALS ARE OFFICE OF NON
GOVERNMENTAL AND PRIVATE SECTOR
COURTNEY HAS BEEN BEING OUT ALL
THESE FOLKS. AND WE'VE GOT
THOUSANDS OF ALL IDEAS AND- I
COULD BE HAPPY SHOULD SHARE
WITH YOU THE LIST OF ALL THE
COMPANIES HAVE COME TOGETHER.
AND TRY TO LEVER THEM IS.
WONDER I WOULD BE USED ALL OF.
AN ONE LAST QUESTION SO GIVEN
JUSTICE AND SCALE OF THE TOWN
THAT WE'VE ALL. EXPERIENCED AND
THAT WE ANTICIPATE GOING
FORWARD. DO YOU THINK
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT. SO IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND RIGHT NOW UNDER
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT THE
GOVERNOR CERTAINLY HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO. IMPLEMENT AND
EQUIVALENT TO DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT AS THE CALL AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. I WILL TELL
YOU THAT WE DID TALK ABOUT
DOING A TO BRING SUCH IN THE
GOVERNOR. WHEN WE BOB WE WERE
CLOSE TO HAVING THAT DONE BUT
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT WHEN THE
GOVERNOR REACHED OUT. AND WE
FRAWLEY'S BUSINESS LEADERS
TOGETHER AND WE WHEN HE WHEN HE
WENT ON PRESS CONFERENCE AND
TALKED ABOUT. COMPANIES BRING
OUT. WE WERE JUST ON WITH THE
AMOUNT OF INTEREST AND SO WE
JUST DIDN'T THINK WE NEEDED TO
ACTUALLY FORMALIZE. STOPPING
THAT WE WERE ALREADY GETTING-
THROUGH THROUGH THE NORMAL
PROCESS. OF TO BE CLEAR THOSE
WE DO HAVE UNDER THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT- UNDER THAT THAT A
FORTY YOU HAVE GRANTED US WEEK
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR CAN.
IMPLEMENT THAT. YOU KNOW AS
NECESSARY OKAY UNDERSTOOD AND
AS WE LOOK FORWARD WHO IS GOING
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR KIND OF
LEADING THIS PP CHARGES THAT
STILL CAN RESIDE IN IN YOUR
DEPARTMENT IN YOUR AUTHORITY OR
IS THERE A TASK FORCE THAT BY
THE GOING TO BE SET UP FOR HAS
BEEN SET UP TO TRY TO REALLY
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE. WELL WE DO
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION WE ARE.
WHEN WE DEAL WITH THESE BIG
EMERGENCIES WE KIND OF BREAK-
THE VARIOUS ASPECTS THAT HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY INTO- TASK
FORCES LIKE SCHOOLS TASK FORCE
OR- RECOVERY TASK FORCE. FOR
TRANSPORTATION. IN THIS THE WE
DID HAVE A- PP- INTERNAL PP
TASK FORCE IT WAS REALLY. IT IS
WHAT THAT YES HAVE SEVEN AS I
MENTIONED AND SHE SUPPORTS
FUNCTIONS SEVEN. REALLY DOES.
BUT WE ADDED A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL ENTITY SO WE BROUGHT
IN. WITH THE GAS IT WE ASK IT
WAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES. IT
WILL. CAL. FEE BY THE F. B. IS
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT AGENCIES
THERE GOV OPS. WE CAME IN AND
BUILT AROUND TO MEET ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ICE I'VE
LISTED IN MY TESTIMONY. THAT
ENTITY WILL REMAIN IN PLACE
UNTIL. THIS IS PASSED AND TO
YOUR POINT THIS IS SOMETHING IS
GOING TO BE ONGOING FOR. YOU
KNOW AT LEAST THE NEXT YEAR- TO
THE LEVEL AND THE GREED OF
ENGAGEMENT WILL DEPEND ON MUCH
WE CAN GET. PP OUT WE HAVE A WE
ASK THE GENERAL WAY WE DO
THINGS IN STATE STATE
OPERATIONS DURING EMERGENCIES
IS WE FILL THE GAPS SO REALLY.
WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON BUILDING AND FILLING
THE GAP ON THE FRONT END WHERE-
YOU CAN'T GET THE COMMODITIES
THROUGH THE NORMAL. PROCESS
EVENTUALLY THE NORMAL PROCESS
WILL STABILIZE AND WE WOULD
EXPECT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
OTHERS TO START PROCURING
THROUGH THE NORMAL PROCESS
INSTEAD OF HAVING THE STATE'S.
TO THEMSELVES WHEN THAT
HAPPENS- NOT REALLY WE'RE NOT
REALLY THERE YET I COULD TELL
YOU PROBABLY BE ANOTHER FEW
WEEKS BEFORE WE CAN GET TO THAT
POINT. OKAY UNDERSTOOD THANK
YOU. ANY QUESTIONS FROM OTHER
MEMBERS SO AB WE'RE GONNA LET
THE DIRECTOR GO SO IF THERE'S
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE FOR THE
DOCTOR WE SHOULD ASK HIM DOWN
BECAUSE THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM
OUR OTHER PANELISTS. MISTER
KAY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AS
I SAID I WAS GOING TO GO AHEAD
LISTEN ALL THE PANELISTS
BEFORE- PUT THE QUESTION BUT IF
THE DIRECTOR IS GOING TO GET
BACK TO WORK CERTAINLY- ONE
ALLOW HIM TO DO THAT. JUDGE
KURDISH DOES SEE A THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED EFFORTS AND
ALL THE HARD WORK. THE FOLKS
OVER CALLOW YES- OR DOING. I
WANT TO. DIVE INTO FOR A SECOND
TO KINDA LASSES WORDS I HEARD
YOU SAY YOU KNOW THEIR LESSONS
LEARNED SOME IS REALLY
CONTRACTS AS I SAID MY OPENING
STATEMENT. I THINK- IT'S EASY
TO BE A MONDAY MORNING
QUARTERBACK. IN THE SENSE OF-
LAYING BLAME AT FOLKS
DOORSTEPS- THE REALITIES
PEOPLE'S LIVES ON THE LINE- THE
GOVERNOR-FOLKS. IN YOUR
DEPARTMENT HEAD THAT QUICKLY-
TO MAKE SURE WE CAN SECURE THE
SUPPLIES AND CERTAINLY. CERTAIN
MODERATE APPROPRIATE. ENACTED
PLEA TO ENSURE THE SAFETY- BUT
CERTAINLY THE- BLUE FLAME IS
THE KIND OF STICKS OUT AS- SOME
REAL ODD STUFF THERE COULD YOU
WALK ME THROUGH CONVALESCENCE
LEARNED- HOW WERE. YOUR WHAT
WHAT PRECAUTIONS ARE IN PLACE
NOW AND ONE THAT COMES TO MIND
IS LIKE YOU KNOW WHO IS
AUTHORIZED I KNOW YOU SAID THE
AGENCY HAD SCREWED. THE
CONTRACTS WE- HAVE WE LIMITED
THAT POOL A GREAT DEAL GOING
FORWARD. I DON'T I WOULDN'T
CHARACTERIZES LIMITING THE POOL
I THINK THAT WE WHEN WE GET IN
THESE LARGE- CONTRACTS- THERE'S
A LOT OF COLLABORATIVE
DISCUSSION AS TO WHETHER WE'RE
GOING TO FORWARD WITH THESE ARE
NOT- IN REAL TIME OF- THERE'S
SO MUCH HAPPENING- NOW UP IN
THE TIME FRAME THAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT- WE'RE WAS
LITERALLY- YOU KNOW WE WERE
HAVING A CASE WHERE. YOU KNOW
WE WOULD GET OPPORTUNITY ARE
AND THEN MINUTES THAT
OPPORTUNITY WAS LOST. HI IT WAS
CHALLENGING FOR ALL OF US EVEN
SEASONED- AND LOGISTICS
SPECIALISTS AND EMERGING
MEASURE PERSONNEL. TO BE ABLE
TO- ADEQUATELY MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THE LARGER DOT IN THE
TEACHER CROSSES MUCH AS WE
POSSIBLY COULD B DOING THAT IN
THE TIME FRAME THAT WE WERE
HAVING STREAM ONLY. EXTREMELY
STRESSFUL ON THE PART OF
EVERYBODY WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT- THAT WERE DOING THE RIGHT
THING. IT'S NOT USUAL. FOR YOU
KNOW EIGHT HUNDRED FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACTS TO BE
PUSHED THROUGH MAY IN THESE BIG
EVENTS EXCEPT WE HAVE A BIG
EARTHQUAKE. OR THE IN THE IN
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FIRES
AND DURING THE CAMPFIRE WE WERE
WE ARE MOVING TO SOME PRETTY
BIG STUFF THROUGH THE DEBRIS
OPERATIONS AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WERE SIGNIFICANTLY. A
SIGNIFICANT- SO WE TAKE A LOT
OF THINGS INTO CONSIDERATION
INCLUDING. THE ABILITY TO. GET
REIMBURSED AND BY THE WAY I DID
MENTION MY TESTIMONY BUT- ONE
THING WE MAKE SURE OF AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WELL WE DON'T MAKE
SURE OF IT IS ONE OF THOSE
FACTORS BECAUSE IF THE IF THE
NEED IS THERE. TO GET AN
EMERGENCY COMMODITY THEN WE
NEED TO DO IT YOUR REGARDLESS
OF THE THREE A PERSON OR NOT.
BUT IN ALMOST ALL THESE CASES
IN REALLY 100% OF THESE CASES.
THE ROLE REIMBURSABLE BY FEMA
UP TO SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. SO
EVERY CONTRACT THAT WE PUT
FORWARD WILL BE REIMBURSED- FEW
ELIGIBILITY BY FEMA AT 75% WE
A HUNDRED PERCENT. FOR THAT WE
CALL EMERGENCY PROTECTIVE
MEASURES THAT'S ALL THE FRONT
AND STUFF THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. AND WE'RE HOPING THAT WE
HEAR SOMETHING BACK SOON- ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN GET THAT
I'M WE'RE HEARING MAYBE COULD
BE 90% BUT UNTIL THEN WE KNOW
FOR A FACT THAT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT TO PROCLAIM THE STATE
AND A NATIONAL DISASTER MAJOR
DISASTER. IT WAS 475%
REIMBURSEMENT. SO WE
COLLECTIVELY LOOK AT ALL OF
THESE THINGS WERE MOVING
FORWARD AND IN THE CASE OF BLUE
FLAME. ARM THE VERY THAT WAS
DONE WAS DONE- AND- AND TO THE
BEST OF THE DEGREE POSSIBLE IN
THE TIME FRAMES THAT THEY- HAD
WORKING AND- ONE OF THE CHECKS
AND BALANCES OF COURSE LIKE ANY
CONTRACT THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH. IS IN OUR COLLABORATION
WITH THE BANK WE TYPICALLY IN
STATE SERVICE DON'T WIRE MONEY.
AT THE TI BEFORE WE DON'T WIRE
MONEY OR THE PERIOD BUT THE
WIRE MONTY TO HAVE TO THE PRIOR
TO GETTING A COMMODITY. IS
REALLY NOT IN THE NORMAL
PROCESS AND SO. THE CONDITIONS
AND THE CIRCUMSTANCES WERE
DICTATING. ARE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT QUE AND WE DID NOT
HAVE TO DO THAT ALL OF THESE
CASES. IN MANY CASES WE FELT
LIKE YOU KNOW WE'VE ADDED THEM
THROUGH AND- THE PERSON WAS
EITHER TO SHADY OR- IT JUST DID
NOT SEEM LIKE THEY COULD
DELIVER. IN THE CASE OF BLUE
FLAME ON AS I MENTIONED ALL THE
THINGS I SPECIFICALLY RIGHT
READ THROUGH. ALL WE FELT LIKE
THERE WAS NO DEROGATORY WE'VE
GONE THROUGH THAT PROCESS. EVEN
TO THE POINT EVEN TALKING TO
THREE AM TO TRY TO GO A
DIFFERENT ROUTE THE LAST MONTH
MINUTE. BUT KNOWING FULL WELL
THAT WE WERE IN DESPERATE NEED
OF AND NINETY FIVE. WE OPTED TO
MOVE FOR WITH IT. AND ONE OF
THE CHECKS AND BALANCE THE
CAUGHT IT WAS- THE BANK- WHO
RECOGNIZE THAT- THAT THAT-
THERE WAS A PROBLEM. THE BANK
THEN NOTIFY BOTH. THE TREASURER
AND ARE OFF I AND THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES.
ALMOST SIMULTANEOUSLY WHICH
POINT. YOU KNOW THAT MIGHT WAS
STOPPED AND WE PULL BACK AND-
YOU KNOW THE REST IS HISTORY
BEING GO THAT ROUTE SO. RIGHT
WE TRY TO PUT MORE YOU KNOW WE
TO IN REAL TIME. EXPANDED WE-
ADDED- FROM THAT POINT- WE
ADDED UP UP AND ELEMENT THAT WE
TYPICALLY DON'T DO DURING
DISASTER CONTRACTING OR REALLY
ANY CONTRACTED FOR THAT MATTER.
AND THAT IS WE BROUGHT IN THIS
THIS TEAM IS LAW ENFORCEMENT
TEAM OR ONE OF THE ROLES OF YES
OF COURSE WE ARE ALSO THE-
HOMELAND SECURITY AGENCY FOR
THE STATE AND SO WE LEVERAGED
ALL OF THE- ABILITY TO DO- TO
USE THOSE. THOSE METHODS AND
SERVICES RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
US ATTORNEY U. S. ATTORNEY AT
THE SAME TIME SINCE THERE WAS
WIDESPREAD FRAUD GOING ON
ACROSS THE COUNTRY- THE US
ATTORNEY OFFICES AROUND THE
UNITED STATES OPEN UP TASK
FORCES ON ON FRAUD. AND ONE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO I TALK TO
THE US ATTORNEY COUPLE OF
TIMES- IMMEDIATELY OFFERED- TO
PARTICIPATE WITH US AS WELL AS
THE FBI OFFICES SACRAMENTO AND
THAT WAS ALSO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE PUT IN. OUGHT TO VET
EIGHT EACH ONE OF THESE THAN
BEING FORWARD. IN THIS THIS OUT.
THANK YOU AND- JUST PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE FOR THE MEMBERS
HERE IN THE PUBLIC- HOW MANY NO
BID CONTRACTS HAVE BEEN ENTERED
TO ENTER INTO- IN RESPONSE. TO
THE CRISIS. AND OKAY ON WHAT
WHAT WHAT THOSE CONTRACTS WORTH
COLLECTIVELY AND WE CAN GET A
GENERAL NUMBER THAT I DON'T
NEED YOU TO PUT IT DOWN EXACTLY.
THE SERMON I DON'T KNOW FOR A
FACT I DO HAVE I THINK ON LINE-
I HAVE- EDGES SHELL FROM OUR
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES AT
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER.
ANGELA DO YOU POSSIBLY KNOW
THAT ANSWER. ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME I CAN HEAR YOU THANK
YOU OKAY- SO WE HAVE ENTERED
INTO- APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY- PURCHASE ORDERS- ON
BEHALF OF THE- GP EFFORT- AT
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS. ZACH NCLUDE
THE B. Y. B. CONTRACT. THAT
DOES NOT INCLUDE THE FULL VALUE
OF THE B. Y. DE CONTRACT NO.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU. MY
FINAL QUESTION- AT THIS TIME-DIRECTOR AND I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO COVER SOME OF THIS.
THE WARRANT PAYMENT PROCESS
THANK YOU TO TREASURES GONNA
WALK US THROUGH AT LEAST IN A
PACKAGE HERE FOR THE MEMBERS TO
TAKE A LOOK AT- CERTAINLY WORKS
TO THE AGENCY HAD TO THE
CONTROLLER TO THE TREASURE SO
IT IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S DESIGNED
IN A WAY THAT'S A FAIRLY
ROBUST- WITH SAFETY- VALVE SO
TO SPEAK. ARE THERE LESSONS
LEARNED WHERE YOU THINK THE
STRUCTURE OF THAT PROCESS.
NEEDS ADDITIONAL STEPS OR ARE
YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THESE KIND
OF OUT LIARS- THAT WE
EXPERIENCED. SUCH AS BLUE FRAME
OR FOR OTHERS. YEAH THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION I THOUGHT A LOT
ABOUT THIS AND I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW. I WOULD SAY THAT.
THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM FOR OUR
REVIEW AND- AFTER ACTION- ON
EVERYONE OF THESE DISASTERS
THEY GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REFLECT. ON HEALTH THINGS COULD
HAVE OPERATED DIFFERENTLY OR
BETTER. AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
THERE'S NO. LINEAR PATHWAY AND
IN THIS PARTICULAR INCIDENT IS
REALLY THE CASE I MEAN THIS WAS
ABOUT AS A SYMMETRICAL IN MANY
WAYS AS THEY GET IN THE IMPACT.
THAT SAID I THINK THAT- THESE
WERE ALL LIARS- THAT THE SYSTEM
THAT HAS BEEN TRIED AND TRUE
AND WE'VE USED IN MANY MANY
MANY MANY DISASTERS- WORKS
WELL- AND- I THINK THAT- EVERY
HUNDRED AND TWENTY YEARS AND
YOU HAVE A PANDEMIC HEY WE
OUGHT TO DO A LITTLE EXTRACTION
BUT- I THINK THAT- THERE WILL
BE NO CERTAINLY I READ LIKE THE
VETTING- THE ENHANCED VETTING
EVERY PUT IN PLACE WHERE MAYBE
WE'VE GOT A- WE'VE THAT-
CONTRACTS OVER STRAIGHTENED OUT
WITH THAT THIS LAW ENFORCEMENT
GROUP- OF WHEAT WE EXPAND OUR
USE UTILIZED BETTER SCHOOLS
MORE TOOLS. TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT UP BUT ALL THAT SAID I DO
BELIEVE THAT THESE. ARE I MEAN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND. OR SO CONTRACTS. AND
VENDORS AND THINGS THAT WE
DEALT WITH AND- REALLY THERE'S
BEEN- A COUPLE ABOUT LIARS
THAT- YOU KNOW WE CAUGHT. THEY
WERE CAUGHT AND- NOBODY WAS
LOST IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT-
THERE'S NOT ALWAYS ROOM FOR
REFLECTION. WELL YEAH I THINK
THAT'S FAIR ANSWER- DIRECTOR
NOW I WOULD SAY. HOT BY THE
BANK AFTER WE'VE GONE THROUGH
SEVERAL GOVERNMENT STEPS I
THINK LEAVES US ALL WITH THE
QUESTION MAYBE THERE'S ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT THERE ON OUR PART
IN OUR PROCESS- ARE YOU. AWARE
OF- ANYTHING OUTSIDE OF WHAT
WE'VE ALL READ THE NEWS AS IT
RELATES TO MICHAEL AND JOHN
THOMAS OR WHO THEY ARE OR WHAT
THEIR RELATIONSHIP- IS A
RELATION TO THE- SECRETARY.
THIRTY EXPLANATION OF HOW WE
GOT THAT FAR ALONG WITH THOSE
TWO INDIVIDUALS HI I HAVE NO
IDEA WHO THOSE TWO INDIVIDUALS
ARE WHAT'S THE NAME. WHAT I
HAVE IS MIKE COOL- IN JOHN
THOMAS LIVE ALSO MORE AWARE OF
WHO THEY ARE NEVER HEARD OF
THEM BUT WANTED TO ASK THE
QUESTION. NO NO CAN I JUST SAY
BACK STEP BACK A SECOND AND SAY
THAT PART OF THE PROCESS. YEAH
YOU KNOW AND IT'S NOT ALL ON
THE BANK BUT PART OF OUR
OVERALL PROCESS INCLUDES THE
BANK. SO WHAT IS NOT LINEAR WE
ALL ARE YOU KNOW IF WE'RE WON
T. ONE FIGHT ON THIS THEIR-
ROLE LOOKING AT THIS AND- AGAIN
I THINK CONTEXT. PLEASE INTO A
LOT OF THE SITUATIONS THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH IN THE IN
THE CASE IN CASE OF BLUE FLAME.
HEY IT WAS CONTACTS AND IT WAS
IN BASED UPON EVERYTHING THAT
SEEM TO BE- LEGITIMATE GIVEN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE TIME
FRAMES THAT WE WERE DEALING
WITH. I THINK THAT'S FAIR POINT
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE LATER TODAY
MEMBERS FROM- THE TREASURER-
AND PERHAPS THE CONTROLLER ARE
WE HERE FOR THE CONTROLLER
MENTION. WE'RE NOT WELL MAYBE
FOR FOLLOW UP HERE AND THERE.
ARE WILL TAKE IF YOU TRIED
WRETCH APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
WORK AND PLEASE PASS ON OUR
GRATITUDE TO THOSE UNIFORM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. Q. THANK
YOU AGAIN DOCTOR FOR JOINING US
AND- WE APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU
WERE DOING TO HELP US NAVIGATE
THIS THIS CRISIS THANK YOU ALL
THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO- OUR SECOND
PANELIST WHO IS. GOING TO BE
TREASURER MAMA ON THAT THE
VIDEO ON THE VIDEO BEHIND US. I
CAN USE YES YOU SEE ME. YES WE
CAN SEE YOU THANK YOU TREASURER
Mà FOR JOINING US RATES. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY THANKING
EVERYONE FOR SHELTERING AT HOME
AND THOSE WHO ARE WORKING IN A
SENSUAL SERVICES. DURING THESE
TRYING TIMES ARE YOU ARE
KEEPING US ALL SAFE IN MAKING
IT ALL WORK. PERSONALLY I HAVE
FELT THE IMPACT OF THE CRISIS
BOTH AT WORK AT THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE. AS WELL AS HOME SINCE
MY HUSBAND IS A FIREFIGHTER.
AND FIRST RESPONDER. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR CONVENING THIS HEARING THIS
HAS BEEN AN UNPRECEDENTED.
LEARNING MOMENTS FOR HAS USE
THAT METAL CHAIR A CAUTIONARY
TALE. BUT ULTIMATELY I THINK
THIS IS A SUCCESS STORY IN THAT
WE HAVE NOT LOST ANY TAXPAYER
MONEY AS DIRECTOR GILDER DG
MENTIONED A NUMBER OF TIMES.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
INTRODUCE MY OFFICE AND WHAT WE
DO. I AM YOUR STATE TREASURER
YOUR BANKER AS PRESCRIBED IN
OUR CONSTITUTION IN EIGHTEEN
FORTY NINE. I OVERSEE THREE
DIVISIONS CHAIR SIXTEEN BOARDS
COMMISSIONS AND AUTHORITIES IN
MINISTER ALL OUTSTANDING BOND
COMMITTEES. IN M. A VOTING
MEMBER OF ABOUT A DOZEN OTHER
FINANCIAL BOARDS. OVER TWO
TRILLION DOLLARS COMES THROUGH
OUR OFFICE EVERY YEAR.
PRESENTLY WE ARE MANAGING A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
SHORT TERM INVESTMENTS FOR THE
STATE ITSELF AND MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. MY
OFFICE ALSO OVERSEES THE SALE
OF STATE BONDS AND ACTIVELY
MANAGES ABOUT NINETY BILLION
DOLLARS IN OUTSTANDING BONDS.
WE ARE A SMALL BUT MIGHTY TEAM
OF FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PROFESSIONALS AT THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. OVERALL I
AM INCREDIBLY PROUD OF HOW OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT IS HANDLING
THIS CRISIS AND IN PARTICULAR
MY TEAM AT THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE. CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
MUST KNOW THAT OUR GOVERNMENT
IS WORKING DILIGENTLY TOWARD
KEEPING US SAFE. PROTECTING THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES ENTRUSTED
TO US. AND FUNCTIONING AS
NORMALLY AS POSSIBLE UNDER
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES. TODAY'S FOCUS IS
ON MY CENTRALIZED TREASURY AND
SECURITIES MANAGEMENT DIVISION.
THERE ARE ABOUT FIVE DOZEN
PEOPLE WHO WORKED IN THIS
DIVISION. SINCE I STARTED AS
TREASURER ON JANUARY SEVENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN. I HAVE FOUND
THIS DIVISION TO BE
HARDWORKING. ETHICAL HIGH
FUNCTIONING PROFESSIONALS
DEDICATED TO SAFEGUARDING THE
STATE'S ASSETS FIRST AND
FOREMOST. I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
THE DIRECTOR AND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WHO ARE BOTH WITH ME
TODAY TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. FIRST I
HAVE MORE CAREER RE. DIVISION
DIRECTOR HE IS A VETERAN OF THE
STATE CHARGES OFFICE FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY TWO YEARS OF STATE
SERVICE. ANDRES RIVERA DEPUTY
DIRECTOR IS ALSO A VETERAN
FINANCIAL PROFESSIONAL WITH
MORE THAN TWENTY TWO YEARS OF
STATE SERVICE. AS ACCOUNTANTS
MYSELF INCLUDED OUR JOB IS TO
TAKE ANTI. EVERY DAY WE BALANCE
ALL OF THE STATE'S MAJORS
ACCOUNTS. ALSO IN SHORT THAT
THERE ARE ADEQUATE ADEQUATE
CONTROLS ON PAYMENTS FROM THE
STATE TREASURY. FOR EXAMPLE FOR
DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS NEED TO
APPROVE A WIRE TRANSFER BEFORE
IT IS RELEASED. IN EIGHTEEN
FORTY NINE OUR FOREFATHERS
ESTABLISHED IN OUR CONSTITUTION
A SEPARATION OF DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. THE GOVERNOR
THE TREASURE IN THE STATE
COMPTROLLER ARE ALL INDEPENDENT
OF ONE ANOTHER BECAUSE THE
FUNCTIONS ARE DIFFERENT FOR
EACH OF OUR AGENCIES AND THE
SEPARATION IS WHAT ENABLES
BETTER CHECKS AND BALANCES. IN
OUR DAILY COURSE OF BUSINESS WE
WORK HAND IN GLOVE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
COVERT NINETEEN HAS DISRUPTED
THE WAY IN WHICH WE LIVE AND DO
BUSINESS. THE FIRST SCHOOL
CLOSED ON MARCH SECOND HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. THE GOVERNOR ISSUED
HIS STAY AT HOME ORDER
BEGINNING MARCH NINETEENTH. AND
AFTER THAT DAY EVERY ASPECT OF
OUR LIVES HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
INCLUDING HOW OUR GOVERNMENT
RUNS. AS A CERTIFIED PUBLIC
ACCOUNTANT CERTIFIED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY TWO. MY
BACKGROUND IN ACCOUNTING
AUDITING PROPER RECORD KEEPING
IN OVERSIGHT HAS BEEN PUT TO
GOOD USE AND HAS PUSHED ME AND
MY TEAM TO HIGHER LEVELS OF
SCRUTINY SINCE STANDARD PAYMENT
PROCESSES HAVE BEEN DISRUPTED.
AFTER MARCH TWENTY SIX I
DIRECTED ANDRE RIVERA TO ALERT
ME WHENEVER THERE IS A LARGE
COBIT NINETEEN RELATED WIRE
TRANSFER. AND HAVE TAKEN IT
UPON OUR OFFICE THAT THESE
VENDORS THE BEST THAT WE CAN.
FROM HAND OUT YOU RECEIVED CALL
THE WARRANT PAYMENT PROCESS.
ILLUSTRATED. YOU WILL SEE THAT
MIGHT MORE MY OFFICE NORMALLY
GET INVOLVED IN STEP SIX AND
SEVEN. WHEN I PAY EACH PRESENTS
A WARRANT THINK OF THIS AS A
NORMAL CHECK FROM A CHECKING
ACCOUNT. FOR PAYMENT AND WE
VERIFY THAT THE WARRANT
PRESENTED IS ON THE LIST OF
ISSUED AND OUTSTANDING WARRANTS
PREPARED BY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER. THE OTHER WAY WE
GET INVOLVED IS WHEN A WIRE
TRANSFER IS REQUESTED. IN THIS
INSTANCE WE HAVE PRESCRIBED
WIRE TRANSFER PROTOCOLS ALSO
BASED ON THE STATE WARRANT
PROCESS THAT WE FOLLOWED BEFORE
WE RELEASE ANYBODY. AS OF.
TODAY MY OFFICE HAS RECEIVED
FOURTEEN PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST
ACT. PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST
REGARDING FOR SPECIFIC VENDORS
SO I WILL ADDRESS THEM NOW AS
THEY RELATE TO MY OFFICE.
NUMBER ONE THE BLUE FLAME
MEDICAL LLC PAYMENT OCCURRED ON
MARCH TWENTY SIXTH. THIS OF
URGENCY AND PANIC TRYING TO GET
SUPPLIES RUSHING TO COMPETE
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
OTHER STATES CREATED THE NEED
FOR EXPEDIENCY WHICH COLOR THE
NORMAL PROCESSES IN SELECTING
AND VETTING APPROVED VENDORS.
AFTER BEING ASSURED FROM THE
FOLKS IN STEP ONE IS TO ONE TO
THREE IN THE WHITE PAYMENT
PROCESS. MY OFFICE INITIATED
THE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR WIRE
TRANSFER THROUGH ONE OF OUR
DEPOSITORY BANKS WHO FLAG THE
TRANSACTION ITH CONCERNS ABOUT
POSSIBLE FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY.
SIMULTANEOUSLY THE VIRGINIA
BANK THAT RECEIVED THE WIRE
CALLED DIRECTOR OF MARK. AND
INFORMED HIM THE ACCOUNT WAS
OPENED A DAY BEFORE BY
WASHINGTON DC BASED LOBBYIST.
AND THE BANK WAS NOT
COMFORTABLE ACCEPTING THIS
LARGE WIRE TRANSFER WHICH IS
WHY WE CLAWED THE MONEY BACK.
PENDING FURTHER CONFIRMATION OF
THE LIFT BUDGET MISSY UP THE
PAYMENTS. THE SECOND VENDOR WAS
HIT JIM HARRISON AND COMPANY
FOR VENTILATORS. ON APRIL THIRD
WE WIRED EIGHT POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO THEIR BANK.
THAT DEAL FELL THROUGH SINCE
THEY COULDN'T SECURE THE
EQUIPMENT SO THEY AGREED TO
REFUND US BACK THE MONEY. ON
APRIL NINTH WE RECEIVED SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
ON APRIL FOURTEENTH WE RECEIVED
THE REMAINING TWO POINT TWO
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS. THE
THIRD CASES B. Y. DE. AND THE
REQUEST TO WIRE FOUR HUNDRED
AND NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ON APRIL TENTH. AS A DOWN
PAYMENT FOR THE ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLAR TOTAL CONTRACT
FOR SURGICAL MASKS AND IN
NINETY FIVE MASS. IN THIS
INSTANCE WE SPECIFICALLY ASKED.
WHETHER THE PROPER VETTING WAS
DONE BY THE FOLKS IN STEP ONE
TO THREE. AFTER BEING ASSURED
IT WAS WE WIRED THE MONEY TO
THE NAME TO MAKE IT COUNT. AS
OF TODAY. SOME OF THE SURGICAL
MASKS HAVE ARRIVED. HOWEVER THE
AND NINETY FIVE MASS HAVE BEEN
DELAYED. B. Y. DEEP REFUNDED US
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WAS DEPOSITED BACK IN OUR
BANK WITH US LAST FRIDAY MAY
EIGHTH. AND FOR THE LAST BENDER
IS BEAR MOUNTAIN DEVELOPMENT
COMPANY L. L. C. ACCORDING TO
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES ARTICLE
ON MAY NINTH. THIS ARTICLE SAID
THAT TGS CANCELED THE BEAR
MOUNTAIN CONTRACT ON MAY SECOND.
MY OFFICE DID NOT WHY ARE ANY
MONEY IN THE BANK ACCOUNT AND
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY PAPERWORK ON
THIS TRANSACTION. IN CLOSING
LET BE AT A RATE THAT THE NEED
TO TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION. YET
TO PRODUCE IMMEDIATE RESULTS.
IMPACTED THE NORMAL CAREFUL AND
DELIBERATE CHECKS AND BALANCES
PROCESSES THAT WERE IN PLACE.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AS CONTROL
AGENCIES WE MUST CONTINUE TO BE
DISCIPLINED SHE WOULD HERE TO
THE PROTOCOLS. OR DEVELOP NEW
EMERGENCY PROTOCOLS THAT WE ALL
AGREE UPON. AND LASTLY DURING
THESE TIMES OF CRISIS WE NEED
TO INCREASE COMMUNICATION AND
COOPERATION AMONG VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS AGENCIES AND WITH
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH SO WE CAN
BE COMPLETELY ACCOUNTABLE TO
YOU AS REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. I THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
AND STEADY HANDS IN PROTECTING
OUR ESSENTIAL FIRST LINE
DEFENDERS WORKERS AS WELL AS
THOSE WHO ARE SHELTERING AT
HOME DURING THESE PAST TWO
MONTHS. I AM ESPECIALLY PROUD
HOWEVER OF MY TEAM WHO STEPPED
UP DURING THE PAST EIGHT WEEKS.
WE AND I STAND READY TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE AND TRANSPARENT IN
MY DUTY AS STATE TREASURER.
THANK YOU WALL WE WILL GET
THROUGH THIS STRONGER TOGETHER.
THANK YOU TREASURER MARK OF FOR
YOUR DETAILED EXPLICATION OF A
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
ARISEN AND ALSO FOR THE AT THE
CHECKS AND BALANCES THAT. ISSUE
AS YOU SAID WERE NEEDED MORE
THAN EVER IN IN THE SITUATIONS
THAT WE CONFRONTED- ODDNESS
RESTAURANTS BONTA COVER
NINETEEN ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. MR GRAY.
IT'S JUST IT'S JUST A PART.
THAT ADDRESS NICE TO SEE YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
OPPOSE THE SAME QUESTION I
POSED TO DIRECT YOUR DO SHE IN
THE SENSE OF KIND OF GOING
FORWARD WHAT DO YOU SEE. AS AN
IMPROVED PROCESS OR DO YOU
THINK WE HAVE ADEQUATE
PROTECTIONS OBVIOUSLY- YOU KNOW
SEVERAL PEOPLE SAID THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF SUCCESS IN A AND IN
SOME SENSE IT IS AS- YOU KNOW
YOUR CAPACITY. AS TREASURER IN
TERMS OFFICE AS PART OF THAT A
MULTI STEP PROCESS- CAUGHT THIS
AND- AND OF COURSE- TAX DOLLARS
WERE NOT LOST. BUT ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL IMPROVEMENTS BE IT
IN PROCESS OR EVEN
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN DIFFERENT
ENTITIES WITHIN GOVERNMENT THAT
COULD AVOID THESE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS. IN THE FUTURE. I
THINK A DURING TIMES OF CRISIS
LIKE THIS- LIKE I SAID MORE
COMMUNICATION BETTER
COORDINATION- IS ALWAYS OF THE
BEST WAY TO GO SINCE MARCH
NINETEENTH MY OFFICE HAS A
STANDING EIGHT AM CALL EVERY
SINGLE MORNING BETWEEN OUR
THREE DIVISIONS JUST TO TALK
ABOUT. FOR TEN CONTRACTS THAT
ARE COMING DOWN THAT WE NEED TO
PAY I ALSO HAVE AN INVESTMENTS
DIVISION THAT INVEST THE MONEY
SO IF A LARGE CONTRACT
OUTCOMES- DO THEN MY INVESTMENT
OFFICE NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE ADEQUATE CASH BECAUSE
WE INVEST ALL IDLE CASH TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE MAKING
ADDITIONAL MONEY. FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO I WOULD SAY
JUST HAVING THREE CONTROL
AGENCY ARE COLLABORATE OR
COMMUNICATE ON A DAILY BASIS I
THINK WOULD DEFINITELY HELP SO
THAT WE DO HAVE A FEW. I'M
ISSUES THE BEST FALL THE CRAP.
THE KEY ORGANIZATIONS BE
CONTROLLER OFFICE SOMEBODY IN
THE GOV OFF AS WELL AS THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE IS THAT MY
UNDERSTANDING CORRECT UP YES
USUALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES IS THE AGENCY
THAT MANAGES ALL CONTRACTS- AS
WELL AS REQUEST. THE PAYMENT OF
THAT THE CONTRACTS AND THEN IT
GOES TO THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE OUT FOR ALSO- VETTING
AND THE WARRANTS PROCESS AND
THEN IT USUALLY COMES TO US. AS
LIKE YOUR BANKER WHERE SOMEONE
PRESENTS THE WARRANT TO BE PAID
OR IN A WIRE TRANSFER SITUATION
THAN WE GET DIRECTLY INVOLVED
IN MAKING THE WIRE TRANSFER.
THANK YOU AND I ALSO ASK THE
SAME QUESTION ASKED DIRECTOR DO
SHE- MIKE GOULET IN JOHN THOMAS
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF. I HAVE
NOT HEARD OF THEM. OKAY AND LET
ME ASK THIS- TREASURE SINCE YOU
HAD SOME EXPERIENCE PREVIOUSLY
SERVING STATE LEGISLATURE.
RIGHT I THINK SOMEONE MAYBE
TALK ABOUT GOING FORWARD MAINLY
MAY NOT BE IN FACT THE PROCESS
WHICH ULTIMATELY WAS SUCCESSFUL
AND ALSO WHY DID NOT RESULT IN
TAXPAYER DOLLARS BEING LOST.
BUT WHAT ARE THE OTHER ISSUES
SURROUNDING SOME RESISTANCE I
THINK WHAT MAY COME UNDER
SCRUTINY OR HAVE SOME-
APPROPRIATE POLICY DISCUSSION
IS KIND OF THE TRANSPARENCY.
AROUND GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
WHETHER IT BE I KNOW THIS
ARTICLE THEY TALK ABOUT
POLITICAL FUNDRAISERS AND
POLITICAL CONSULTANTS BUT
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS- CONSULTED
CETERA. BEING INVOLVED IN STATE
CONTRACTING A LOT OF THAT PART
OF STATE GOVERNMENT ISN'T
SUBJECT TO THE SAME- DISCLOSURE
RULES THAT MANY OF US ARE
SUBJECT TO YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
SOMEBODY TAKES MISTER DEAN TO
LUNCHEON SPENDS TWELVE DOLLARS-
THAT REQUIRE SOMEONE REPORTING.
RIGHT CAN YOU GERMAN OPINION ON
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S AN AREA
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO DIVE
INTO TO RACKSTRAW STRENGTH IN
THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OR
TAKE SOME ACTIONS TO MAKE SURE-
THAT THOSE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES
OR OR THE APPROPRIATE. PARENTS
EXISTS AROUND CONTRACT. WELL
ABSOLUTELY- WE ALL HAVE TO FILE
FOR SEVEN HUNDRED FOR EXAMPLE
EVERY YEAR TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE DISCLOSING ANY POTENTIAL
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST SO ARE
ANY- MEASURES THAT SEEKS TO- TO
CREATE MORE TRANSPARENCY A
SPECIALLY IN PUBLIC CONTRACTING
I THINK- IS ALWAYS UP THE RIGHT
COURSE OF ACTION. AT THIS POINT
ARE YOU SATISFIED WITH THE
UNKNOWN- YOU'VE MENTIONED SOME
SOME INCREASED KIND OF
PROTOCOLS ARE YOU SATISFIED
WITH THE ENHANCEMENTS AS FAR AS
THE VETTING PROCESS CONCERNED
GOING FORWARD FROM THIS DAY.
FORWARD DURING THIS CRISIS. I'M
LIKE I SAID WE ONLY A ARE
BETTING THE WIRE TRANSFER
REQUESTS BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE
ONLY. INFORMATION OR REQUEST
THAT COME DIRECTLY TO US. IF
THE CONTROLLER AT ISSUES A
WARRANT MEANING. SEND THE CHECK
TO A PAY HE WE DON'T
NECESSARILY KNOW WHAT CHECKS OR
PAYMENTS ARE GOING TO AND WE
CERTAINLY DON'T SEE ANY OF THE
CONTRACTS SO- I'M KIND OF AT
THE BACK END OF THE
TRANSACTIONS- WOULD LOVE TO BE
MORE INVOLVED IF THE PARTIES
WOULD LIKE U. CURRENTLY THE
WAY THE SYSTEM WORKS IS- WE ARE
REALLY- AT THE BACK END OF THE
COLD WAR- PROCESS SO PERHAPS MY
QUESTIONS BETTER. DIRECTED TO
THE CONTROLLER- AT AT THE TIME
THAT WE HAVE THE CONTROL OF THE
FOREST TO ASK THOSE QUESTIONS
AND I BROUGHT THAT UP WITH THE
CHAIR ON THE PERHAPS- WE NEED
TO INVITE THE CONTROLLER TO BE
PART OF AN ADDITIONAL HEARING
OR OR HAVE SOME COMMUNICATION
IS NOT TO BE HERE COULD BE MORE
INFORMAL OR- A LETTER FROM THE-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OR- MAYBE
FROM. A COUPLE OF THE
COMMITTEE'S BUT SEEMS LIKE WE
SHOULD GET SOME OF THOSE
ANSWERS AS WELL AS- THE OTHER
AGENCIES INVOLVED IN CONTRACT.
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT
SUGGESTION MR GRAY LET'S WORK
ON THAT TOGETHER. THAT'S ALL
THE QUESTIONS I HAVE AT THIS
TIME SO ALL YOU'LL TO MY
COLLEAGUES. NUMBER HI I JUST I
WILL FIRST I WANT TO SAY I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS BEEN A
COMPLICATED TIME AND I REALLY
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PART- IN THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES SYSTEM IN JUST BACK
TO- MR GRAY'S QUESTION ABOUT
COMMUNICATION I WHAT IS
COMMUNICATION RIGHT NOW LOOK
LIKE WITH YOU TRADITIONALLY
BEING REQUIRED TO JUST TRANSFER
THE MONEY WHAT WHAT IS YOUR
TRADITIONAL ROLE IN THAT
COMMUNICATION AND WHAT DO YOU
SEE FOR SEE IN THE FUTURE AS
THE COMMUNICATION BETWEEN YOU
D. G. S. AT OUR GENERAL
SERVICES SORRY. AND OTHER
CONTROLLER. SO I'M GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO AN EXPERT SO I DON'T
MISS SPEAK- SO I'M GONNA HAVE
ANDRE COME UP AND MAYBE. JUST
DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
SOME OF THE- PROCESSES- AND HOW
OUR OFFICE. IS INVOLVED IN
THESE TRANSACTIONS THANKS. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON. SO TYPICALLY-
WHAT WHAT HAPPENS IS FAR AS
PAYMENTS ARE CONCERNED IS HE IS
A DEPARTMENT OBVIOUSLY WILL
HAVE EITHER CONTRACT WORK- AMY
CAN THESE BE MADE AND TYPICALLY
THAT WILL HAPPEN THROUGH- THEN
WORKING WITH THE CONTROLLER AND
CREATING A CLAIMS GET DON'T
THAT CLEAN SCHEDULE GOING OVER
TO THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
OF THE CUT THAT WAR EITHER ONE
OF TWO THINGS WILL HAPPEN.
EITHER THE WAR OR EMAIL
DIRECTLY OUT TO THE VENDOR- AND
IN WHICH THE TREASURER SAID WE
WILL NOT HAVE ANY DIRECT
CORRESPONDENCE- IT WILL WORK-
ON THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT IS IF
THAT IF THE VENDOR IS
REQUESTING WIRED TO BE.
SUBMITTED THEY WILL THEN- FOR
THAT WAR TO OUR OFFICE AND THEN
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
SINCE THAT DIRECTLY TO US AND
THEN WE GET WIRE TRANSFER
INFORMATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
AND WE WILL IN FACT WIRED THE
MONEY ON THE CHURCHES THE PARK.
TYPICALLY HOW WE ARE. SO THE
STAFF FROM THE DEPARTMENT WILL
BE A CONTACT WITH OUR OFFICE
SERIOUS WIRING INSTRUCTIONS-
AND WE'RE COMMUNICATING BACK
AND FORTH THIS IS FAR AS THE
AMOUNT. THE DATE THAT THE- THE
WAR IS TO GO OUT MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE WARRANT BEFORE
WE SEND OUT ANYTHING. ANYTHING
OUT OF THE STATE TREASURY SO
THE TREASURER IS NOT ALLOWED TO
SAY ANYTHING OUTSIDE IT THE
TREASURY WITHOUT A TO THE
DRAWING BOARD. AND ONCE WE HAVE
THAT IN HERE THAT'S WHAT. IT'S
THAT'S CHEAPER HOW WE HANDLE
COMMUNICATE BUT IN THIS CASE
BEING THAT. YOU KNOW THE
PROCESS IS TYPICALLY THAT THE
VENDORS THAT IT UP FRONT- BY
THE DEPARTMENT. AND WE AND THEN
SUBMITTED TO THE CONTROLLERS
HERE WHO DOES THE PACKAGE
COUNTY. MAKE SURE THERE'S A
CORPORATION THE MONEY'S IN THE
IN THE FINAL CORRECTLY BEFORE
THEY RELEASE A WAR. SO ALL THE
CHECKS AND BALANCES OF
TYPICALLY THERE. IN IN THIS
CASE- WE WERE RELYING UPON THE
DEPARTMENT DOING THE VETTING
WHICH THEY TYPICALLY DO- WHICH
THREE AND AGAIN. WITHOUT THAT'S
PROCESS WHICH WOULD NORMALLY
TAKE- BUT COME TO FIND OUT
LATER THAT IN THIS CASE
OBVIOUSLY TO HURRY YES. AVE YOU
KNOW THAT THAT THAT THAT PIECE
TO BE JUST A BIT A CHECKED. AND
THAT'S PART THAT. HE THAT PART
OF THE COMMUNITY NINE IN
STRENGTH THAT TO BE SURE THE
BETTING IS DONE OF ANYTHING. IT
SOUNDS AS IF YES INDEED YES IS
NOW. A DONE. A DIFFERENT TAKE
ON THAT MEETING IF. HAVE NOW
INCLUDED THE THEY HAVE INCLUDED
OTHER RESORT IS TO HELP THAT UP
FRONT. I THINK THAT GOES A LONG
WAYS TO- SATISFYING SOME OF
THAT NEED- DEBBIE FROM EARLIER.
NOT KNOWING EXACTLY WHO THE
PLAYERS WERE BEHIND SCENES OF
YOU TRANSACTION NOW SOME OF
THAT VETTING. TO BE A BEING
DONE AND I THINK THAT'S- A VERY
GOOD THING. YOUR SIGN UP.
THROUGH THE CHAIR. SO WHEN
YOU'RE ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
COMMUNICATION YOU ARE NOT
REQUESTING THAT YOU BECOME PART
OF THE- I DID THE VETTING%
PROCESS CORRECT ANYMORE THAN
YOU TRADITIONALLY ARE. THAT IS
CORRECT I THINK BECAUSE YOU'RE
PROCESS DIDN'T WORK IN ESSENCE.
THAT IS CORRECT. THANK YOU.
WHAT THANK YOU MADAM TREASURE I
DO HAVE ONE I ONE MORE QUESTION
TO I THINK YOU FOR THAT
RECOMMENDATION- WHICH I THINK
IS VERY SOUND IN TERMS OF JUST
THE NEED FOR ENHANCED
COMMUNICATION PARTICULARLY IN
THIS TIME OF CRISIS WHEN WE ARE
UNDERSTANDABLY WORKING IN AN
ENVIRONMENT- PANICKED AND OF
DESPERATION BUT SAID THAT
SOMETHING THAT- I HOPE WE TAKE
FOR IT AND I'M HOPEFUL AND THE
FOUR DETECTIVES WORKING WITH
YOU TO TAKE THAT FORWARD- AGAIN
THAT TO MR GRAY'S IS MYSTERY
POINTED OUT YOU PREVIOUSLY
SERVED HERE IN THIS BODY. WITH
YOUR LEGISLATURE WITH WITH YOUR
HAT ON AS A LEGISLATOR ARE
THERE OTHER PLACES WHERE YOU
THINK YOU KNOW CASH NOW THAT
I'VE GOT THIS VANTAGE POINT
THAT IS THE STATE TREASURER IN
THIS MOMEN OF CRISIS HERE ARE
SOME PLACES WHERE PERHAPS OUR
LAWS NEED TO BE STRENGTHENED TO
FURTHER PROTECT CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS. WHAT I THINK THE
NECESSARY CHECKS AND BALANCES
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE- BETWEEN THE
CONTROL AGENCIES- BUT LIKE.
EVERYBODY ALLUDED TO- THINGS
WERE HAPPENING VERY QUICKLY-
JUST COMPETING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND OTHER STATES. UP
FOR THE PP OUT REALLY-
SHORTENED TO WORK- CURTAILED
THE NORMAL VETTING PROCESSES
AND CHECKS AND BALANCES THAT
USUALLY HAPPENS SO. NOW THAT I
THINK THINGS HAVE CALMED DOWN A
LITTLE BIT AND- DEPARTMENT- YES.
ERECTOR COLLEGIATE G. HAS UP
FORMED A LARGER COMMITTEE ACT
OF THAT THE VENDORS- I THINK
THAT IS A VERY GOOD THING THAT
SHOULD HAPPEN. AND ON OUR END
FOR EVERY WIRE TRANSFER REQUEST
THAT COMES TO US WE ARE ALSO
DOING THE- BETTING BECAUSE
THESE VENDORS ARE NEW TO US-
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN IN THE
SYSTEM FOR A LONG TIME. AND SO
WE ARE ALSO TAKING THAT EXTRA-
STEP AND DUE DILIGENCE. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US- FOR SHARING YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AND FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU DO FOR CALIFORNIA
AND FOR CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR
AND AT THE RIGHT NOW WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR LAST
PANEL- HE- HAD TO LEAVE IT ON
THE PHONE OR IS IT GOING TO BE
ON ANOTHER. TELEVISION WE'RE
GOING TO BE TRYING TO BUY. A
HELEN CHRISTINE WHO IS THE
PRINCIPAL FISCAL AND POLICY
ANALYST. OF FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS HELEN THIRTY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
YOU HEAR ME OK. WE CAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY AND ALLOWING
ME TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. I
HAVE MADE YOU COMMENT THAT WE
WANTED TO PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY I PREFERRED IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL COVER NINETEEN
EARLY. AND HAD MERGED AS THE
COUPLE WORKING. OF BACK YELL
AND REALLY UNPRECEDENTED IN A
LOT OF WAYS. I THINK CREATED
REALLY AN UNPRECEDENTED NEED
FOR GOODS AND SERVICES BUDGET
PP. AND THEN MINISTRATION.
QUICKLY TO THE COUNTRY. GET
SERVICES WE THINK THAT MAKES
SENSE BUT THE TWO. REALLY
CREATED SOME OVER SHALL FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE FOR THE LARGEST
IN SO I'M GONNA TALK A LITTLE
BIT SOME OF THE CHALLENGES. I'M
IN MY REMARKS TODAY. THERE FROM
OUR OR TWO OVER THE KIND OF
JOHN THERE OF IN HERE. IN THAT
SPECIAL. THERE AND BY DURING
THE DOCTORS IN A. HE PRACTICES
THAT WHEN I ABOUT VERY QUICKLY
THE FIRST IS AND WITH A BIT
ABOUT THIS ALREADY TODAY BUT I
DO YOU PREFER COUNTRY.
CONTRACTORS THAT CONTRACTING
WORLD DURING EMERGING COULD YOU
THAT. THERE WAS REQUIRED
COMPETITIVE BIDDING AND YOU
THREE MOBILE BED PUBLIC I.
BEFORE THE STATE INTEREST THE
COUNTRY. I MEAN THIS IS REALLY
TO TRY TO ENSURE THAT THEY GET
THE LOWEST PRICE AND IT'S A
FAIR. EVERY TO GET THE STATE
BUSINESS HOWEVER THESE WILL.
ADRIAN EMERGENCY. IT'S AN
IMPORTANT RATIONALE FOR THIS
WE'VE HEARD THIS IS REALLY A
LIKE OR DEATH SITUATION BE
PROCUREMENT YOU HAPPEN VERY
QUICKLY AND GO THROUGH THE NET
OFF BETWEEN WERE BUT THE
VETTING IS AND HOW QUICKLY THE
STATE MOVES THAT WOULD SORT OF
GO GO ON THAT YOU HAVE TOWARD
QUICKER AND HELLO BUT LACKS
REAL BAD WHAT THE TYPICAL
PROCUREMENT- AND THERE'S
CERTAINLY A REASON FOR THAT BUT
IT DOES MEAN THAT THE TYPE OF
PART OF THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAD TO GIVE. YOU THE
LEGISLATURE CONFIDENT
CONTRACTOR GONNA BE FAIR AND
EVERYTHING'S GOING TO GO AT
THAT JEFF ISSUE BUT- A WEEK
BECAUSE IT THROUGH THE PROCESS
THE FACT THAT THE- A LITTLE BIT
OF THAT AND COURSE I'M WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT THAT AND
TODAY AND INCLUDE BY A BIT
ABOUT THE WAY THE GO MAKING THE
PROBLEM. WELL. KIND OF PIECES
THE FUNDING UP FOR. TO THE
FUNDS APPROACH IS ALSO
DIFFERENT THE NUMBER. COULD YOU.
THE CURRENT HAVE SECRET FOR THE
LARGEST TO THE CUTS AND IT
GIVES A LOT REALLY GET OFF TO.
SEEK INFORMATION ON HOW BY WILL
BE ON THE PROCUREMENT CRACKED
THAT WILL BE USED AND ANY OTHER
THAT THE LEGISLATURE BILL BUT
NEW TO DECIDE WHETHER TO
PROVIDE THE FUN. HOWEVER AT
THREE MERGING CZ MINISTRY.
LEADERS TO OTHER CRAP THAT THE-
PARTICULAR USE CONNECTED TO THE
BACK THOUGHT EMERGENCY
OPERATION ACCOUNT. AND IT
DOESN'T TO HAVE EVEN IF YOU TO
KEEP A I JUST APPROPRIATION
PROCESS FOR THAT SO IF YOU
COULD CAN ACT THE DISCOUNT
WOULD YOU. SEVEN OF THE FUNDS
ECONOMIC AND- THAT A PART OF
THE THREE ACCOUNT. WHAT PRIOR
NOTICE. OR OFFERING THE FROM
THE WHAT. SO THERE'S A REQUIRE.
AFTER FACT BASED THAT THE
MINISTRATION NOTIFY THE LIKE.
WHAT BUDGET COMMITTEE BUT AFTER
AT THEIR NO. REQUIRE FOR THE
REQUIREMENTS TODAY. OUT BUT.
I'M DIDN'T GET MAKES IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE COUNTY COULD
LEAD TO. I KNOW I GET YEAH BUT
I THINK. A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT THAT MOST REGENCIES MOST
KIND OF DISASTERS HAPPEN
QUICKLY EITHER THINGS LIKE WHAT
WILD HAIRED HAPPEN OVER A
RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
TO GET WELL IT'S THE RESPONSE A
DEFINED GEOGRAPHIC AREA WITHIN
THE STATE. OCTOBER NINETEEN.
THE WERE THOUGHT TO BE PRO LONG
GET COULD BE OLD HERE PERHAPS
AND IT CERTAINLY AFFECTS NOT
ONLY THE STATE. OF WORLDWIDE.
AND IT IS REALLY INCREASES THE
SCALE AND THE LENGTH OF TIME
OVER WHICH NUMBER TO BE
PROCUREMENT TAKE FIVE I'M NOT
REALLY RIVAS THEY- ARE RELATED
TO AFFECTED OVERSIGHT AND NEEDS
ARE AND WE FOR. YOU DID FOR
ENTRY IN. EXTREME ALLERGIC. YOU
KNOW HUNDRED DIDN'T OF THE OVER
BILLION IN SOME CASES. I'M
ENTITIES EMERGENCY PROCESSES
THAT AREN'T QUITE AS REQUESTED
AGAIN THERE'S A REASON FOR
THAT. AND IT MAKES HOUSING WHEN
YOUR SECURING THE VERY LARGE
CONTACT A LOT OF MONEY BUT- I'M
TO REALLY IF THAT MAKES IT KIND
OF A TOUGH SITUATION. AND
FINALLY I WANTED TO HIDE IF
YOU'RE TRANSFERRING BE. AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE. HI LATE BET
PARTICULAR PRETTY COVERED HIGH
TRANSPARENCY IS A CHALLENGE AND
I THINK PART OF THAT IS BEEN
THE REASONS THAT I MENTIONED A
MINUTE AND THE REASON THAT
WE'RE JUST GOT. TO PLAY IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL REGARDING THE
NATURE OF THE EMERGENCY HOW
QUICKLY C<c.cyan> HAD TO ACT HOW</c>
SENSITIVE INFORMATION- INDICATE
THE QUIET. BUT WITH THAT SIDE
RIGHT WELL SOME INFORMATION.
YOU HAVE PROVIDED. ASIANS THE
LEGISLATURE FOR. WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THING THAT
THE DOCTOR COME EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT FOR
ACCESSING THE AFFECTED
APPROPRIATIONS LEGISLATURE
MADE- THREE WHAT KIND A SECTION
THIRTY SIX PROCESS. IN MANY
CASES THERE WERE SIGNIFICANT
GAP. OF HER UP WITH THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME OFTEN SEVERAL
WEEKS AND THERE WERE SOME CASES
MULTIPLE REQUESTS. FOR THIS
INFORMATION. THE ONE EXAMPLE IS
THE RECENT YOU ID CONTRACT
WHICH HAD BEEN THE FACT THAT AT
THE MONEY. THE LEGISLATURE
JACKET AGAIN FOR. ON THE
CONTRACT IN A TIMELY MANNER I'M
FROM THE KIND OF INFORMATION
THAT THAT- YOU'RE SPEAKING FROM
OUR OFFICE AS WELL AS OTHER
LEGISLATIVE STAFFERS AND I
REMEMBER THE TWELFTH. GRADE
THINGS LIKE THE COST AND
DOCUMENTS PURCHASES. I KEY
TERMS OF THE CONTRACT.
ADDITIONALLY. TO THE VENDOR
WHAT I. AND THE FOR HOW THE
HALF THE ALLOCATED FOR EXAMPLE
DIFFERENT. GROUPS I AND REALLY
WHAT WHAT PORTION OF THE
IDENTIFIED NEED BE THOUGHT
ABOUT CONTRA. CHALLENGING TO
GET THAT INFORMATION. THE
ADMINISTRATION BAKER MY COUNTRY
TO GET WHAT PLAN I HAVE TO GET
BACK IN FROM ON THE CONTRACT
THAT THAT COULD PROVIDE. YEAH I
NEVER GOT THE QUESTION BUT BEEN.
A PRETTY FOR PROPER. I'M
ADDITIONALLY. PRESSURE IN THE
THERE IN THE THAT THERE ARE
NUMBER OTHER LIKE COUNTRY.
BECAUSE YOU DAY. ACTUALLY THAT
THE DIRECTOR SPOKE SOME OF THE
MOST. I DON'T ON POINT B.
UNDERSTAND THAT THE MYSTERY HAS
TODAY. SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE- WE
HAVEN'T READ OFFICIAL BUT IF.
AND SO THAT REFERENCE THE FACT
FOR I SECTION THIRTY SIX OR
GOOD ACTORS MERGING PERSONAL ID
YOU CHEN. AQUA EXACTLY WITH THE
FUNDING FOR YOU FOR THE- HI AN
EXACT KIND OF HOW THEY THEY
OPTED TO GO. I'M AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
INFORMATION WE NEED PUBLIC
INPUT ON THE WEB. WANT THE
TRUTH APART WE GOT. BUT BUT I
THINK IT'S- TIME TO GO THEM
FROM THAT. THAT CAN MEET NOW.
I'M AND I THINK CONTRACT HAD
BEEN PLACED SOMETIME. SO WE DO
THINK THAT. BASIC CON THREE
MILLION FOR ON. IT IS
PARTICULARLY THE FOR THE
LARGEST TO ENSURE CAL AND
PERFORM OVER AND BUT THE- ROLE
FOR THE LEAD. IN ALLEGE THE I.
HAD HAD VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
OUR- OVER ANYTHING THE NEAR THE
STATE'S. BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND STARTED THAT IT TO CHAO
IMAGE OF DIFFICULT POSITION OF
WELL OF COURSE THERE TO QUICKLY
A COURSE THEY'RE TRYING PROTECT.
THE STATE MAKE SURE ACTUALLY
GET ALL P. I'M VERY VERY
DIFFICULT POSITION BUT THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO REALLY HAVE AN
INTEREST GETTING. TIMELY CAN
FOR. CONTRACT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FUNDING APPROACH BANK.
LIGHT EMERGENCY AND BEAT THIS
IS A PROTRACTED SITUATION WITH
WITH NO END IN SIGHT SO THAT
POINT. IS VERY WELL TAKEN I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS BUT
ME FOR SEE. ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WITH QUESTIONS. OKAY I'M SO LET
ME JUST ASK YOU A COUPLE OF
THINGS SO. IT BELIEVE. THAT AND
THAT THAT YOU WOULD HAD REYES
ANY YOUR SHARED WITH A SOME OF
YOUR- A PARTICULAR TRANSPARENT.
NOW ARE THERE ANY SPECIFIC
CHANGES THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IMPLEMENTED IN ORDER. TO
ENHANCE OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AS WE MOVE FORWARD OUR THROUGH
THIS CRISIS. SO THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE STILL WERE
ON AND SOMETHING ABOUT I. EIGHT
NINETEEN HAS REALLY. SOME OF
THESE CHEN IN A WAY THE THAT
HADN'T THE CASE THE THIS IS
THAT THE THAT BURKE SORT OF.
ONGOING ON GOOD POINT DON'T
HAVE RECOMMENDATION BUT IT
MIGHT GIVE YOU A COUPLE THINGS
MAYBE AT THE ABOUT I THINK ALL
OF ANY KIND OF CHANGE FOR
THIRTY TO TRADE OFTEN. AND
OFTEN IT THE TRADE OFF IS. YOU
KNOW IS. NEEDED THINGS OVER
WERE. AND YOU KNOW THERE'S A
BIT MORE IT TERMS OF DEAL
THROUGH BUT THEN YOU KNOW MAYBE
THERE'S MORE ON THE REAL. I
HAVE HAD SOME ADDITIONAL AT
MEASURE THAN THEIR SOUNDS LIKE
IT MINUTES CAN'T OR WORKING
SOME OF THOSE THINGS IN
CORPORATE TO REVIEW FROM FOR
EXAMPLE AND- THE ARE THOSE ARE
GOOD THAT BUT OF COURSE THE
ADDITIONAL THAT COULD BE. A
MORE ADDITIONAL. COULD BE AND
FOR ACTUAL COMMUNICATION. AS
WHICH WHICH AS WELL THAT ARE
THE TYPE OF THING YOU CAN ON
THE CURRENT FIVE. GET A
PROBABLY TREAT OFTEN AND THEN
YOU ASK THREE OF ADDITIONAL
YEAH THE MARTIN LOOKING DOWN SO
IT'S NOT NOT REALLY AN EASY
BACK THERE COULD BE CHANGES ON
THAT BY. BY THE COULD YOU CAN.
FOR I'M AT THE MENTION DOCTOR
EMERGENCY UP ACCOUNT. BEAR
QUITE A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
TERMS THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THE LEGISLATURE ON
THERE OKAY AS- THE CATION. AND
IN GENERAL I- ONE OF. THE
THINGS THAT COULD BE CONSIDERED
IS JUST ADDING MORE
TRANSPARENCY. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AFTER THE FACT.
THAT INCREASED ONLY NET
ORGANIZE THEM FOR ME THAT
PROVIDED TO THE LAW. WHAT
LEGISLATURE PROJECT ON CONTRACT
THAT COULD BE SOMETHING THAT
CONSIDERED. HEARD OF. NUMBER
CONTRACTING I THINK BUT TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY JACKSON KEEPING.
AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE A CON
THAT THE HAD INTO FOR NON HI
THE ACTIVITIES TO THANK SO
REALLY THE GALLAGHER LARGE AND
I THINK THE REALLY SMALL
PROCUREMENT THAT WAS THE BIG
FOR HOW THAT YOUR SPECIAL THE
VERY LARGE PROCUREMENT FOR A
LOT OF FUN EFFECT. THAT. YOU
REALLY HAVE BIG BUDGETARY AND-
YOU FOR THE STATE SOMETHING
GOES AWRY. AND WITH VISA THAT
HE AND IF DARK. THAT'S FOR IN
TO THE CASE SCENARIO. AND WOULD
BE THAT WOULD BE YEAH VERY
DIFFICULT PARTICULAR GIVEN THAT
SOMEBODY COME VERY VERY LARGE
THINK WHAT I HAVE AND HAVE YET.
AND AS WE HEARD AT IT YOU CAN
BE ABLE TO GET BACK ALL OF IT.
BUT I THINK THOSE ARE KIND OF
THING THAT ARE. EVERYONE AT
CERTAINLY MAKES YOU DON'T
HAPPEN AND SO EVERYONE MAKES
THAT THE FINE TO SPECIALLY WHEN
THERE'S LARGE VALUE. I THINK A
REALLY SPENT IN A FAIR WAY OF
WELL SO I THINK YOU KNOW DID
YOU FOCUS CERTAIN. OF AS WELL.
IF YOU THINK THEY GOT YOU HAVE
THE OPTION THEY ALL HAVE TREAT
A- WE HAVEN'T YET AND- IF I
SPECIFIC RECOMMEND. BUT I BUT I
THINK THAT THE CASE OF AREAS
THAT LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER.
ADMISSIBLE IT TRYING TO WHAT HE
HOW. HOW TO PASS ADDRESS IT
OKAY HOPE YOU KNOW WHAT I HOPE
YOU DON'T EITHER SITUATION.
NINETEEN PATIENT- WITH US ON ON
THIS AND THAT THANKS FOR
SHARING YOUR PERSPECTIVE. AND
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU
AGAIN AS WE MOVE FORWARD. AND
THAT WITH THAT I THINK WHAT
WILL GO AHEAD AND DO IS OPEN
THIS UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. S
I EIGHT SAID AT TODAY WE HAVE A
FEW OPTIONS FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
HERE IN THE ROOM- BY PHONE AND
BY EMAIL- WOULD CHECK SO IF
ANYONE IF THERE'S ANY MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC IN THE ROOM I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. I DO RIGHT NOW
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HANDS AND
I'LL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE IN OUR TELEPHONE COMMENT
ARE WE WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC CAN PROVIDE THEIR
COMMENTS. THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. HI THIS IS THE
NUMBER THAT IS ON THE WEBSITE
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING HEARING NOW.
THE ACCESS CODE TO DIAL IN IS
TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. AND IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
UP ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACE
IN THE QUEUE. RIGHT WE ARE
ALSO. ACCEPTING OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT- VIA EMAIL. YOU CAN
EMAIL COMMITTEE STAFF YOUR
COMMENTS. THEIR EMAIL ADDRESSES
ARE LISTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. ALL RIGHT- MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. CHECK
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE PHONE
LINE IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION OR
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PROVIDE YOU FURTHER
INSTRUCTIONS ONCE AGAIN FROM
THE PHONES IT'S ONE ZERO. THE
RESULT IN THE QUEUE. WE ALLOWED
A FEW MOMENTS THERE ARE NO
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM THE PHONE
LINES AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT UP WELL. I
THINK YOU MEMBERS FOR JOINING
US THANK YOU AGAIN TO ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS FOR PARTICIPATING
I THINK THIS WAS. A VALUABLE
AND INSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATION.
UP TODAY IN A CRISIS AND I
THINK ALWAYS ARE OUR NUMBER ONE
GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT. WE ARE.
ENSURING THAT WE ARE SPENDING
OUR TAX DOLLARS EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY THAT WE HAVE FOR
BEST VETTING PROCESS SEES IN
PLACE. TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
TAXPAYERS AND- THAT IS A SAID
OUR GOAL IN A CRISIS AND OUR
GOAL ALWAYS I THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US AND WITH THAT WE ARE
DIRT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THAT
DOES CONCLUDE YOUR CONFERENCE
FOR TODAY.